I would say that the criticism that has
been made here today,
>> yes,
>> is fundamentally racist because it's
doesn't match reality and it is
basically rooted in the idea of I'm
scared of Muslims and I don't want to
live with them. You made a pretty
outrageous
>> which one
>> claim about churches being attacked
>> and you went on the internet and you
didn't find it. You are what they call,
and I've never really encountered one,
and I'm happy to do so, and this isn't
an offense, but you are what they call a
woke person, aren't you?
>> Uh, yeah.
>> I'm going to say this, people are going
to lose their, but it's true. You have
to start shooting people if they attempt
to come over the border.
>> I actually,
>> but if somebody has another way, I'm
completely willing to to listen to it. I
think the cameraman left. He was Did
that offend you? I think it offended him
so deeply he left the room.
>> Are you serious?
>> Yeah. Reed, let's bring the camera guy
up here and ask him his solution. So,
what would your solution be to illegal
immigration in Europe?
>> Undocumented immigrants commit less
crimes and less violent crimes.
>> But that doesn't answer the question,
though. So, what is the solution to
illegal immigration in Europe?
>> And the facts don't support your
feelings about the issue. And the facts
are that especially in America,
undocumented immigrants commit less
crime.
>> We're talking about Western Europe.
>> So, we're talking about Western Europe.
I believe the statistics are fairly
similar. Well, that's how people sounded
during Jim Crow era. Hey, if we allow
different races into these
>> Here's the thing. I think people like
you assume that the people who do this
are all white. Blacks, browns, and
yellows do the same thing. If you told
them, hey, we're going to introduce a
boatload of whites to the point where
you're going to become maybe a minority.
Blacks, browns, and yellows would resist
it even more. So, it's not a racial
thing. It's just a human thing. This is
our country. We want it our way, our
culture, and our people. That's just the
world. It's not like a white racial
thing. Let's say the UK says we're
British and Germans says we're Germans.
We don't want non whatever into our
country. Do they have that right?
>> Well, and what I would say is that's
when we back up and we look at the
history of imperialism. If you want to
talk about violence, if you want to
>> but yes or no. I just I'm looking for a
yes.
>> Well, of course you're looking for a
simple answer.
>> So, you don't believe in sovereignty of
a nation? Sovereignty is largely um
something that is used to oppress
people. Most of the people coming to
Europe are refugees from European
actions. I think immigration is a human
right. I'm against uh dictatorship. I'm
against uh the dictatorship in Saudi
Arabia and I'm also against oppression
of of Muslims here in America as well. I
believe in freedom which means the
freedom to be Christian and the freedom
to be Muslim wherever you are in the
world.
>> How about the freedom to have my own
country without anyone coming in? Have
you read any arguments against your
position?
>> Of course.
>> Okay. Give me an example of something
you've read.
>> Well, what you just witnessed is but the
tip of the iceberg of what's coming up.
Some background. Peter Beosian, the
infamous street epistemologist, invited
me for a no holes barred interview in a
Los Angeles studio. I accepted and what
followed was arguably one of the most
comprehensive discussions I've ever had
on all the big civilizational questions
of the age with of course a focus on
Islam's growing role in the West. Now,
as is my want and custom, I held no
punches back, calling it as I see it, as
did Peter. The result? Well, you just
saw a glimpse of it. The cameramen who
were hired to record the interview, that
is to perform a job were outraged by our
conversation, which in retrospect may
not be all that surprising considering
that we were in LA. One bailed out
early, something about having to go home
and feed his cat. Peter has that story
on his substack. Link in the
description. The other cameraman,
however, completely lost it, or as the
kids say, crashed out. As you'll see,
however, this was a great treat for me.
For this man, this person was my first
brush with a truly quintessential woke
person. Up until then, I really thought
woke people were imaginary, that they
didn't really exist in the real world. I
thought there were mythical characters,
or rather caricatures, parodies of
extremely liberal people designed to
make us laugh. As you will see, however,
they are very real. So sit back now,
relax, and I hope am confident that you
will find the following video both
edifying and entertaining and not a
little disturbing. Given Islam's growing
presence in the west, is Islam a
religion at peace?
>> Well, well, that goes way way back. Uh
it was very popular with George W. Bush
actually
>> and okay, we have to do a little
etmology because this is an interesting
question. We got to look at the words.
>> Okay. And uh the trick is that the word
Islam is connected to the word peace
salam in Arabic. And um you know long
story short in Arabic you have these
three roots three uh usually consonal
roots without vowels. And where you put
the vowels and mix it around you get
different related words. So salam is
peace. Islam literally means submission.
>> Right?
>> But the logic is once you submit you
have peace. M so for example Muhammad
sent letters according to the Islamic
tradition to the kings around him the
non-Muslim kings Christians or Astrians
and whatnot and it was just two words
Islam tlam and now teslam is another
word means be safe so okay and it's
connected to peace and connected to
submission so what doeslam means it
means submit have peace be safe okay so
that's the truth about what it is so
when people tell you though that Islam
means peace they're really pulling out
of contest context because it does
there's no peace unless you submit.
That's the religion. Okay? And so all of
Islam is basically jihad and and and
aggression until one submits. A Muslim
we call Muslims, but it's pronounced
Muslim. Again, that's connected to the
word salam, Islam, Muslim is one who has
surrendered or submitted. And then the
question becomes so submit to what? What
are we submitting to? Well, the law of
God, Allah's which becomes Sharia law.
Okay, which is as we know, you know,
people I think have an idea. It's pretty
draconian. Um, definitely antithetical
to modern standard humanitarian law. So
that that right there is one of the big
issues when we talk about is Islam
peaceful and Islam's presence in the
West. Um, yes and no. It's peaceful if
you surrender to it, which is probably
why we're seeing so many people in the
West acquiescing one way or the other,
being passive towards it. But that's uh
that will give them peace of a sort. But
it's going to require their total
surrender one way or the other as either
by converting eventually or becoming in
in the historical tradition vimmies
which is secondass citizens in their own
homeland who accept it and uh allow
Muslims to live really to lord over
them. That that's really the most
accurate description of u in my mind
when I hear this thing about Islam being
peace
>> and then then they have to pay a jer
tax, right?
>> A jiza tax. Yeah, that's that's all.
Yeah, that's the classical Islamic
Jewish prudence and understanding based
on Sharia and it expressed itself all
throughout history. So, it's not just an
abstract thing. It's in the Quran.
>> And once they pay that tax, is it safe
to say that they're historically that
they've been safe?
>> Hey, did you know only half of you
watching are subscribed? If you're
enjoying the content, hit the subscribe
button to keep the videos coming.
Thanks.
>> Well, see, now this is another
interesting point. a lot the apologetics
and the sort of like in intellectual
gymnastics that the apologists for Islam
and the west engage in are are are very
uh interesting and so one of them is
this. So for the longest time what
they've said is uh here's what Jiza is.
Jiza is according to Quran 9:29 it says
fight the people of the book or the
scriptuaries which is understood in
Islamic Jewish prudence as Christians
and Jews the people who came before
Muslims who had scriptures. Okay,
they're the people of the book. So fight
them until either they convert to Islam
or pay jiza. Yeah.
>> While feeling themselves subdued. Okay.
Now the word jiza is actually connected
in Arabic to the idea of a substitution.
So instead of you killing me, I'm giving
you money. I'm I'm ransoming myself
because my life is forfeit because I'm
an infidel basically.
>> Yeah. I' I've argued that. Sorry to
interrupt. I've argued that that the
British people should do that for years.
>> Yeah, I know you have. And we'll get
into that.
>> Yeah. Anyway, so when you do that, you
you pay the you the Jiza and you pay it.
Okay, but what comes along with the Jiza
then is this entire host of
discriminatory measures that you as the
demi or the infidel have to live under.
So for example um you know my family's
from Egypt or Coptic Christians the
indigenous um in inhabitants of Egypt
just like all the Middle East was the
indigenous people were Christians. So
when they get conquered they have to pay
the tribute. But then also there's a
host of debilitation. You can't build
churches. You can't repair churches. You
can't ring the church bell. You can't
show a cross. You can't uh show a Bible
around a Muslim. You can't try to
proitize. But if Muslims proitize to
your people, you can't interfere. You
have to get up and give them their your
seat. Okay. So it's like you're a
secondass citizen. So that's what comes
with the idea of Jiza.
>> What if you're an atheist? How do you
fair into that?
>> Well, okay. under historically that
never happened because historically
there were really no atheists but today
uh it would you would fare under so in
classical Islamic Jewish prudence
there's really two groups there's the
people of the book they're the lucky
ones Christians and Jews and sometimes
depending on who it is it could be
zerastrians and then there's just
outand-out pagans I think uh today's
atheists would be considered out-and-out
pagans and the p out and-out pagans
don't even have the chance to pay
tribute they have to actually convert or
die and that actually was uh manifest
against the Hindus for the longest time.
So they weren't considered people of the
book and according to reliable
statistics in five centuries something
like 80 million Hindus were killed
during the jihad because you either
convert or you die until the Muslims
reached the point and said you know what
we're going to extend to them the
scriptatory people of the book status
just because we've killed enough of them
let's at least make some money out of
this.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Okay. So that's why I mean there's
some elasticity uh you know to to how
this Jizia thing works. But to go back
to what I was trying to say is the
academic lies. So now when they talk
about Jiza professors say yeah the Jizia
was this tax that Christians and Jews
had to pay to get protection from
surrounding Muslims. Yes.
>> That's what they teach. As if the
implication is like some Mongol horde is
going to come attack and the Muslims are
going to go defend the Christians and
the Jews. No. The protections from the
Muslims themselves.
Okay, that's the protection you're
paying. So, it's almost like a mafia
racket. You pay me to protect you and if
you don't, I'm going to hurt you. Okay,
that's actually how it really expressed
itself historically.
>> So, again, going back to the theme of
Islamic immigration in the West, is
there any argument for allowing a
significant number of female Muslims
into the into countries
>> as opposed to males? Like like
preferring female Muslims as opposed to
males? Is there an argument for or
against that?
>> Uh, well, I've heard the argument
against
male.
>> Okay. Because they're militant perhaps.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But is there an argument?
Because I know when we were in Taiwan,
many Muslims from Indonesia go with I
think 10ear visas if me correctly. Is
that right?
>> And they have almost no problems over
there whatsoever. Female Muslims. Is
there an argument against female
Muslims? Well, I mean, I think the
argument is generically uh females of
all religions and races are less
problematic when it comes to the law. I
mean, if you look in whatever race,
color, religion, or creed, you're going
to find more males probably in jail,
more males engaged in violence um in
that sense. So, I think it also would
agree with the Muslim women thing, but I
don't think Muslims in general would not
would allow for that because they're
very cohesive.
>> I can't imagine a Muslim family sending
their daughters alone. that would
actually be very counterproductive
because they'd worry that they would
assimilate and become corrupt in the
west.
>> Uh you know the whole honor killing
thing.
>> Yeah. I'm curious. Have you followed
much of this talk about inbreeding? Have
you followed this?
>> You mean like the Ilhan Omar marrying
her brother and this?
>> Well, like part in certain cultures,
Somali, the Pakistanis. I had Colin
Wright, evolutionary biologist from the
Manhattan Institute on the show to talk
about that. and
there have been an old interview with
Joe Rogan and uh he was a proud boy
Gavin McGuinness
>> uh he goes over the statistics of
inbreeding
>> in Islamic countries are there higher
incidents of inbreeding
>> I think there is um I don't think it
it's correct though to associate it with
Islam per se I think it's more of a
cultural practice that uh really
transcends the religious
>> but they separate the males and the
females right so how you can't go
there's no dating scene there's no
>> what it's just very common for kind of
like cousins to marry. Like that's not
considered too close.
>> Like
>> first cousins.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean they don't marry the sisters. I
mean maybe they do but that that that's
kind of considered that's frowned upon I
think even amongst Muslims but it's very
common to marry your first cousin.
>> Wow. So culturally have have you been
following the uh Somali fraud ring at
all?
>> The a little bit. Um, but I mean I
>> I mean, yeah, it's interesting because,
you know, many people have claimed that
Somali have IQ's equivalent to those
people who are mentally disabled, but
the fraud empire they build in Minnesota
is actually incredible in scale and
complexity. Do you think those two
things can be squared?
>> No, I do. Um,
you know, there's there's two ways to
look at it. So, Somali, and I know
President Trump said this very recently.
I don't know if you're familiar with it.
He had this sort of like he crashed out
on the Somali
like terrible get out of my country and
yeah
>> well I mean there's some truth to what
he's saying it's one of the most failed
states in the world Somalia.
>> Okay and at the same time it's also you
know radical Islam is par for the
course. Somalia when you look at and
this is a good way to look at a litmus
test. You know I always one of the ways
to see how radical or dysfunctional
society is is to look at how the
Christian minorities are treated and it
habitually ranks something like second
third worst nation in the world
>> of how it treats Christians and
persecutes them. Okay. So that's the
mentality that we are bringing in here
and I've dealt with a fair bit of
Somali. I used to work at the Library of
Congress in Washington DC and there were
a lot of them there and um yeah I mean
not I wouldn't want to live in a Somali
neighborhood let's put it that way okay
tri very very tribal and then the
Islamic aspect even gives you know
solidifies and gives it that sort of
jihadist veneer but the fact that
they're engaged in fraudulent activities
that's no of you you'll find a lot of
people who can't run their own home and
their countries are falling apart but
they're really good at scandalous
fraudulent behavior and exploiting the
system. So I don't think they're they're
mutually exclusive that on the one hand
their countries leave much to desiring
because of their own culture and on the
other hand that they're exploiting the
system which also we have to add is
because of American policies being so
liberal and in a way stupid and allowing
themselves to be exploited so easily.
>> Yeah, we've talked about that before in
our conversation. So you've written a
lot about how Christians in Nigeria
being slaughtered by by Muslims,
>> but as a culture, you know, Americans
never really cared about Africa. For
instance, just this year, literally
hundreds of thousands of people have
died in Sudan alone, and there's been
almost complete and total silence from
from Western media. So why should we
suddenly start caring about Christians
dying in Nigeria? Like, why does that
matter to us?
>> Well, I mean, the question to me isn't
if a person should or shouldn't care. I
mean, I think that's up to them, but
it's revealing to me. I think that's the
more interesting aspect why people don't
care. You know, on the one hand, we're
supposed to care when George Floyd, one
black man who's a criminal, dies and the
whole world, the whole country is set a
flame because black lives matter, we're
told. On the other hand, as you just
indicated, there's a genocide against
black people and we don't even think
it's worth mentioning.
>> So, there's obviously a disconnect there
and there's a lot of hypocrisy clearly.
Thank you.
going on. So on the one hand I think
what's happening in to Nigerian
Christians and all throughout Africa
actually subsaharan Africa
>> is in it has many lessons. One again is
Islam because the people who are
persecuting them are Muslims. In
Nigeria, it's entirely an Islamic
assault. Whether it's Islamic terror
groups, Boka Haram or whether it's the
fanis who are just Islamic tribesmen or
you know going back to Somalia, you got
Elshabe which is a terrorist
organization and Elshabe literally means
the youth. So the youth who are pious
are terrorists. Okay. in Somalia, Mosamb
beek, the Democratic Republic of Congo,
they're just every other month I read
about they trap Christians in a church
and set it on fire or behead 50 or 60 of
them, you know. So, it's it's mass
carnage all in the all in the name of
Islam and jihad and Allah and Christians
are being killed. So, at the very least,
I think this is a learning experience
for Westerners even if they don't care.
>> We won't learn.
>> I know. I know. But at least you see,
okay, here's Islam. Here's Islam. you
know, when it's when when it's the thing
about Africa, what's interesting is, for
example, Nigeria where it's a it's a
genocide, they're actually about 50/50
population wise. 50% Christian, 50%
Muslim. And that gives you an indication
of when Muslims are your strength, it's
going to be an allout war. And you see
some of this in Europe as well, because
there's actually a theory, and I've I've
written about it before, but depending
on the um percentage of a Muslim
population and a non-Muslim, there's
certain dynamics that happen. Okay. So,
when it's very small like in America,
you're going to have a lot of the crying
about human rights and freedom and we're
we're being persecuted. We are etc. And
it makes sense to most Western people.
But then as that number grows, it
becomes a little more militant, a little
more violent. So when you go to Europe,
when you go to France, when you go to
the UK, it's not just vocal now. Now
there's actual violence and aggression.
>> I have two questions for you.
>> Okay. One is the reason for that that
and we've had two Muslim apologists on
the show and we've scheduled to have two
more come on in the last interview he
said it's explicitly political Islam is
explicitly political in a way that
Christianity render under Caesar is not
is that one reason and then the second
thing is immediately before this
interview you said something that was
just shocking to me that two churches a
day are desecrated in France.
>> I'm utterly blown away. And you wrote
about that
>> years ago. If you could tell us about
that. I found that fascinating. If
that's okay.
>> Sure. Sure. I'll start with that because
that's fresher now, the the church
thing.
>> Uh so, okay. I uh I've for since about
2011, I've been very among the different
topics and themes that I write about and
talk about, one has been the Muslim
persecution of Christians. One can say
I'm the expert on that. I've written a
book literally. I have a book out on it,
Crucified Again. And since 2011 till
today, I publish monthly reports.
They're published at the Gatesstone
Institute. Each about 4,000 words. Okay?
Which for the month in question, I I
scour the internet. I have contacts and
I get all the um accounts of Muslim
persecution of Christians around the
world. Okay. So the question of what
happens to churches in Europe has always
been on my radar for the longest time
because it's actually it's not
necessarily persecution of Christians,
but again it's a litmus test of
hostility for Christians.
>> In fact, I find it more telling when an
inanimate object like a church or even
worse and this even happens just as
frequently attacks and desecration of
cemeteries, Christian cemeteries, okay,
and breaking crosses and decapitating
statues of Mary and exuming bodies of
Christians and spilling them. This is
pretty common in Europe and of course in
the Islamic world. The most recently it
happened in October in Syria, okay?
Where they and I saw the pictures very
macob stuff just Christian bodies dumped
that have been dead for 50 years. Okay.
So my point in telling you that is
attacks on churches and cemeteries to me
really underscore the hatred more so
than an attack on a Christian human.
Because when you attack a human, well,
there's a human factor here. You know, I
know you, you know me. Maybe maybe
there's something above and beyond the
religious dimension.
>> Oh, I'd hope so. Yeah. But when you're
attacking a dead building,
>> Yeah.
>> because it has a cross. Okay. That tells
me what you're really motivated by. So,
having really followed this, I came
across numerous reports for years about
uh France is just one of them, but I I
read and you can probably still find it,
but then they they expunge it off the
internet because I read about it and I
wrote it and I hyperl in articles and
then I go back two years later and
everything I hyperl is gone. It's been
wiped out. Okay. But if you do your
research, you'll find it. And it was a
lot. It was I think a human rights
organization complaining about Aaho in
France. Two churches every single day on
average are desecrated.
>> That just blows my mind. Yeah. Who who's
desecrating them?
>> Okay, so here's the thing. Obviously
these most of these attacks you don't
they just happen. You know, Christians
come to the church and it's been
desecrated. But sometimes there's
telling signs and sometimes the person
gets caught. sometimes often it is a
Muslim and there's Arabic writing aloh
Akbar and and this sort of thing and
they urinate in the baptismal fonts and
they spit on the Eucharist and they go
and I mean France is where of course
those Muslims went in Nice and you know
cut an 80-year-old priest's throat right
so these attacks have been going but
it's not just France okay so um I've
read a recent report um that came out by
the I think it's called the Intolerance
Observatory and it was about the rise of
anti-Christianism in Europe and they
focused especially on attacks on
churches. And what I found very telling
is they they listed the worst countries
in order and the worst was France and I
think the second or third were Germany
and the UK and I think the fourth was
Italy and what was funny about that is
if you look the the numbers actually
were commensurate with Islamic
populations. So France does have the
largest Muslim population and then
whether it's the UK or or or Germany, I
I I remember looking it up, the number
two place did have the second highest
Muslim population and the third one had
it. So we definitely know Muslims. I
wouldn't say it's always Muslims. There
are they claim there's leftists who are
attacking them. Satanists and so forth.
I can't it's hard to tell. That's what
they say. Yeah. That's what they
>> 100 Satanists there are.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean I think the majority
of it of course is is uh Muslims who are
doing this and attacking it and that's
why you know you know the Snopes. Are
you familiar with Snopes?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So um there's a French site and I think
it's called the Islamophobic Observatory
and um sometime before or after
Notraam's burning. Oh yeah.
>> Which I believe was 2019.
>> I think it was an accident.
>> No. Yeah. I'm not saying it's not but
I'm going to tell you. So, right around
when that happened though, um they
published a map of France and it showed
where every, you know, where um they had
a red dot for wherever a church was
burned or attacked or desecrated and
basically France was red. Okay? It was
entirely red. You couldn't see a spot
that wasn't. And it was kind of like,
you know, so we know all those are
arson. We know sometimes we catch Muslim
culprits who are behind it. But all of a
sudden, Notradam, you know, was they
were telling us it was a forensic or or
they were telling us it was an accident
before the fires were even out, before a
forensic analysis could even be done.
Now, I'm not saying it wasn't. I don't
know. I wasn't there,
>> right?
>> But at the same time, I wouldn't be
surprised if it was arson.
>> So, I know that people are going to be
listening to this and say, "Oh, that's
bullshit." So, what are some sources
about the claims of churches in France?
Like, where can somebody go to find out
about
>> The problem is, to be honest with you,
this stuff disappears. Okay? I mean, if
if you want if you I can pull up my
computer and I can find stuff for you,
but um
>> send it to us in the in the
>> I will I will I'll send it to you. But
if you go on Google and and say it,
nothing will show up. You have to like I
have to go into the, you know, the dark
web and the deep net and use these
browsers that are not, you know,
controlled
>> and you don't ask AI because AI is going
to lie and conceal. And I know
>> less so Grock and more so Chach. I just
had a I I did a live stream a few days
ago with me and Grock and he Do you want
to know how bad the lie was?
>> Really?
>> You want me to tell you?
>> Yeah, tell me.
>> This is an interesting story.
>> Um and again, it deals with Islam in
Europe. So, um someone sent me a one
minute video.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's a it's it's about this wise
sultan, an Ottoman Sultan who during the
Irish famine
>> Oh. G gave Yeah. Yeah.
>> Someone So, the guy I had on my show
literally just talked to me about this.
Okay. Okay. So the story for those who
don't know is um an a young Ottoman
sultan heard about the famine of the
Irish and he was just so moved and he
just wanted to send all this money but
the queen of England blocked him because
she was paying less.
>> That was the story he said.
>> Okay. She was paying less and uh she
said you're going to embarrass me. So
she asked him to pay less and he did but
then behind her back he sent ships with
foods and supplies. And then it's it's a
place called Dragodada I guess uh where
where those both showed up. And the
message of the video I watch is you
Irish people owe the Muslims. Okay,
that's that's the takeaway. So,
so I I you know the 19th century is not
my forte historically. I know a fair bit
and can speak with some authority about
Islam and Europe. But I just so I was
like on the couch and it was kind of
evening. So I had Gro on. I was like
who's this Sultan? And it told me the
same story. It said oh he's this
well-known sultan who out of benevolence
and altruism did blah blah blah. Okay
long story short I did a whole live
stream. I actually put up grock and you
can see it and I speak to it. It I I
started pushing it and pushing it and
and then finally he said, "Okay, it was
80% uh sincerity, 20% real politique."
>> That's the word I actually used. Okay.
And I kept pushing it and bringing up
points and facts that most people
wouldn't know until it said, "Okay, I I
it said respect. You got me." It was 95%
rail politique. It was an Ottoman trying
to curry favor of the British. He didn't
even want to send it until his ministers
told him so they can help him in the
Crimean war against Russia.
>> So, but he didn't tell you that upfront.
>> Well, yeah. And I even told him, well,
why didn't you tell me that up front?
And it was like, you know, you're right.
I should have told you up front, but I
decided to give you what what the Irish
public schools teach.
>> So, it's basically saying Irish public
schools lie, too. Wow.
>> Um, yeah, it was I was I was shocked the
level and but the the more you push it,
the more you push it. So it went from
telling me it was 100% a true story like
that guy that you spoke to telling me
yeah it's all lies.
>> Wow that's fascinating. Wow that's so
>> that's what we got to deal with with
this AI business.
>> Yeah. So I want to explore an area of
disagreement that we have.
>> So we and please correct me if I'm
wrong. So I think we disagree about how
Darwinian we should be in our views
towards civilizational competition. So,
do you think a society that doesn't
believe in reproduction deserves to
continue? And so, why shouldn't we just
give Western Europe to the Muslims? I
mean, they're going to take it
eventually anyway. So, why not just give
it to them
>> now? And we can save lives in the
future. We can negotiate a lower tax on
non-Muslims. Maybe we can prevent, you
know, let the Jews flee. Maybe we can
say minimal only 10 years in prison for
homosexuals. Like like I I think that's
a disagreement that we have.
>> No. No. Yeah. Yeah. And I'm more than
happy to but actually but I'd have you
first kind of like really articulate
what you're saying. Like when you say we
give up, I I what am I going to give up
or what are you giving up?
>> Well, I'm not I don't live there. I
don't
>> Yeah. Yeah. What do you mean like the
European?
>> I could negotiate their surrender for
them.
>> Surrender in what sense? Kind of like to
do what exactly?
>> Well, I first of all, I wouldn't worry
about the logistics of this. I think
this is more the sentiment that the
demographic it is demographically
inevitable right
>> that there will be a takeover and I
don't think that they've come the whole
problem this is a problem of first
principles the problem is that they have
failed to be honest about the problem
>> so
I think the way to think about this
problem is to minimize future murder
mayhem by negotiating a surrender now
>> so you're saying if the Europeans
surrender to the Muslims the Muslims
won't have cause to rise up and do
terrorist.
>> No. Well, we can figure out, again, this
is a logistic issue. We can divide it
between Iran and and Saudi Arabia or
maybe we could put Pakistan in there or
what have you because it is inevitable
that it will come. I mean, I think we
agree on that.
>> Okay. So,
>> but we dis because I don't think there's
any political will whatsoever. I don't
think they can stop the flow of
immigrants. I don't think they're being
honest about the problem. I think
they're still lying. I think Starmmer is
still lying about it. I think Sadik Khan
is lying about I think they're all lying
about I think McCrron is lying about it.
I think they're all lying about it.
>> All right,
>> so why not start being honest about it?
>> Okay, very good. Uh I think that's a
great uh uh question observation. So my
response is I largely agree with you
that they're lying and even worse. I
mean lying is one way to look at it, but
in many ways they're just traitors,
okay, to their own nations. Um it really
comes down to the people. So the
question is most people will tell you,
well I don't agree with that. I thought,
you know, but I think what you're saying
is that the people, whatever they say,
and no matter how militant they sound,
they're just not going to do anything is
what you're saying. Of course, when it's
all
>> I mean, they already haven't done it. So
why are there suddenly
>> because they still have faith in the
system. So what if they what if they
realize the system doesn't work for
them? Okay, theoretically. And uh but I
think it's still a good observation
because I do believe even if they knew
in their heart of their hearts that the
system doesn't work for them and they
have to rise up, I think many of them
can't. And I think that is for decades
that has been the project of this grand
you know sort of emasculation of men or
trying to trying to tell men you know ju
just enjoy life and what's this
protecting and whatever go do whatever
um and I think people have become so
soft and comfortable
>> that actually when the time come and
that's by design so when the time comes
they can't get up and fight you know a
lot of I I know a lot of guys in America
where you know I'm stockpiling my
weapons I'm doing this and that and
>> and you know whether that guy will or
won't act up on that. Even if he does,
he's like one in a million.
>> He won't matter.
>> Okay.
>> You know, number-wise,
>> because most Americans and most
Westerners are just so
>> also have the second amendment here.
They don't have
>> Yeah. Yeah. Europe more reason to think
to be
>> right. Yeah. Yeah. That's a major issue,
too. I mean, physically that they don't
have that. Um, but I think, in other
words, I'm trying to think of how a
European would respond.
>> I mean, the longer they lie about it,
the worse it's just going to be. But it
but the liars are their leaders. And the
problem is the populists are just naive
and dumb. The the populace needs to
understand that it's it's a broken
system. They're not going to come. They
don't have your back. Okay? It's not
about voting for that guy. This is what
I mean. Everyone still has this hope.
And this is sort of the thing with the
United States. You know, Trump,
the whole thing with MAGA, and I'm not
attacking Trump, but you know, it's we
always have we put all our eggs in one
basket. there's one guy who's going to
come, one politician is going to take
care of it. And the problem is it's not
about that. It's not about this
individual politician. It's about the
culture itself. The culture is rotten.
>> Well, that's why the culture is dying.
>> Shouldn't we look at it in a kind of
Darwinian way like the European culture,
West Western European, I think that's an
important qualifier.
>> Please push back if you disagree, is
dying. Their citizenry thinks that there
are things they're not worth fighting
for. They've And the thing that you said
to me in our last interview that was so
interesting is they're not invading.
>> They're being welcomed in.
>> Yeah.
>> And so that adds an additional dimension
of complicity with this. And so maybe
there's just not nothing. I mean, if
their own people don't think it's worth
fighting for,
>> maybe there's
>> the problem is all the gaslighting. The
problem is all the okay so the the
average people the the normal native
Europeans okay a lot of them kind of
like in a very sub in a very simple way
get it and and and understand this wrong
but they just still have so much when
they think what can I do oh it's about
let's uh let's um you know let's vote
for that guy he's going to take care of
us and I think they need to realize no
that's not gonna do it for you
>> yeah it's okay so let me let me ask you
this so I had a guy this Muslim
apologist on the show and I asked him.
Why is it that people pray, Muslims pray
in the streets in Western Europe? Again,
the key word is Western. You don't see
that in Budapest. You don't see that in
Poland. Why is it Yeah. Why is it they
pray in the streets in Western Europe,
but they don't do that in Saudi Arabia
or Iran?
>> And he said to me, "Well, it's because
it's forbidden under Islam." And I'm
said, "Well, why do they do it then?"
>> To provoke and to make a point. It's a
provocation. And then it's a making a
point that we're here. We're taking
over. All right. So, so let me let me
ask you a question. Tell me I'm going to
push back on my own argument. Like how
much push back do you think there is
among Muslims to the Islamization of
Europe? And should we really be talking
about Muslims as though they're one
coherent group? Is there a lot of push
back?
>> You mean you mean Muslims in Europe who
are against the radicalization?
>> Yeah. Muslims Muslims in Europe who are
like, man, I don't want Sharia. I want I
like my freedom. You can be I like a
secular state if if you know because I
can be Muslim and and I don't care if
you're Muslim.
>> Yeah. I I I mean, okay, a guy like that
probably does exist, but to what extent
can we even call him a Muslim at this
point? Because if you prefer secularism
as opposed to Sharia, then how are you
even a Muslim in the first place?
>> You can't be a cafeteria Muslim.
>> I think you can. Nobody's going to kill
you. Well, I won't kill you. Maybe your
relatives will kill you, but you know
what I mean. But I mean we can you can
do anything and you can believe in
anything. But then there's normative
Islam where of course if a Muslim comes
up in an Islamic country and says I
don't want I disavow Sharia. Yeah.
You're going to get in trouble. Okay. So
um and it makes and I don't even blame
them because it is intellectually
inconsistent to say I submit remember
the word Muslim. I submit. Submit to
what? To the law of Allah. So if I say I
don't want to submit to the law of
Allah. I enjoy secularism but I'm a
Muslim. Well okay now you're being a
hypocrite. So I don't think I think
there's a lot of people named Muhammad
in the west who who could fit this
profile. But I think in their heart of
hearts they don't even see themselves as
Muslims uh anymore. A lot of these could
be you know secret apostates or just at
most cultural Muslims. Okay. But I don't
think they're the majority. I think the
drive of tribalism is and cohesiveness
is very compelling for humans in
general. And it's and it's very much
manifest amongst Muslims. That's why you
see these displays where they go and
fall down and pray by the droves. Uh
whereas Europeans, you know, they're
very isolated. They're very
individualistic. They've kind of been
stripped of all sort of uh cultural
mooring that they have nothing to uh you
know, to stand to rally behind anymore.
In England, we spoke about it before,
just just their own flag. You know, the
St. George flag became this humongous
controversial, you know, scandal
>> and they're taking the flags down and
erecting Palestinian flags.
>> Yeah, it is. It is a takeover and
especially in places like the UK. I
think what people need to understand is
look all throughout history if you
wanted change and your leaders didn't do
it you you resorted to violence. I'm
sorry to say it.
>> Well, like in Ireland there there I have
seen videos about people threatening to
take the law into their own hands of
which I personally do not advocate.
>> I'm not advocating either. I'm just
saying this is the natural uh
consequence. So what what did the
founding fathers do? I mean on the one
hand there are these great enlightened
luminaries right Thomas Jefferson and
these people on the other hand they
rebelled and said okay we don't you
don't we don't want you know taxation
with our representation which is nothing
compared to what people are suffering
now
>> okay and that was enough for them to go
to war and it was justified it was seen
as a just war so your average westerner
now is being abused you know so
incrementally that they've just become
used to it like the boiling frog they
don't even realize how bad it is but in
their mind. They can't conceive that I'm
going to actually resort to violence.
And part of that is because they've been
so um you know, pacified, emasculated.
They can't they can't do violence. That
was the that's the whole program for
decades, convincing men, you know, not
to be man, not not to do anything
masculine, not you know, violence is the
worst thing in the universe, etc., etc.
And
>> along with racism.
>> Yeah. Well, yeah. With that, too, of
course.
>> Yeah. So, you know, you write a lot
about the dangers of Islam, the problems
of Islam, alerting to people, but as far
as I can tell, and please correct me if
I'm wrong, Southeast Asian Muslims, and
I I think they're around 250 million,
they pose almost no danger to society or
to the West. So, I'm wondering, is the
problem Islam or is it is the Islamic
culture that's unique to the Middle
East?
There's not the Islam is inherently
fundamentally in and of itself
intrinsically violent and intolerant.
Period. Now, having said that, whoever
subscribes to it, of course, you're
going to have a sort of synretatism with
their own culture
>> and with their own idiosyncratic um
societal ways and that may indeed temper
Islamic uh you know, Islamic how Islam
expresses itself. And so, yeah,
absolutely. if you look at but they're
not you know people have this idea
Indonesia and these places are just you
know there actually there's pretty
there's a lot of radicalization there
too there's a lot of violence there's
terrorist groups there's attacks on
churches so it happens there it's not
quite as bad as you know Somalia or
Nigeria but it is there and that those
lists that I tell you that rank
countries places like Indonesia will pop
up it won't be anywhere near it won't be
in the top 10 but they're there so I
think of course there's room for human
culture and society and their own their
own normative expression and that may in
fact temper uh how Islam itself
expresses but Islam itself the good
thing about Islam is it's so black and
white it's not an abstract uh religion
about as you indicated earlier it's not
about render to Caesar to Caesar it is a
political ideology okay when I say I'm a
Muslim I'm submitting well that's an act
it's not an idea I'm submitting to laws
I I embrace these laws laws. Now, if a
Muslim doesn't really follow them, okay,
if a a Muslim society doesn't follow
them, yeah, they can do that. But the
religion itself is the religion itself.
>> So, that leads me to my next question.
How do you know that Islam is inherently
violent? So, if if you're going just by
scripture, isn't that true for
Christians as well, the Bible, like come
with a sword, etc.
>> Right. Right. Okay. So, the difference
is this. You have the scriptures, but
it's not just the scriptures. So, you
have the calls to violence in the Quran.
Then you have what's the hadith, the
teachings of Muhammad. Okay? And
Muhammad's considered the perfect
example. Every Muslim is supposed to
follow him. Okay? And the hadith, you
know, or the Sunnah, which is the
example of the prophet as derived from
the hadith is essentially there with the
Quran, the twin pillars of Islamic
epistemology, if you will, and that is
full of violence and intolerance. Okay?
So both the Quran and the Hadith more so
the Islamic jurists who are looked upon
the as they're called have distilled
Islamic law based on these two texts and
they conclude that things like jihad is
absolutely obligatory which is I have to
go fight and conquer and spread Islam
and subjugate the infidel etc etc that I
have to place the dimmi or you know the
the you know secondass status and and
okay the whole nine yards okay so that's
Islam so it's in the text it's in their
law. Okay? And you know, look around
Muslim countries, I see it's still
happening. Okay? So, there's a reason
that when you look at the 50 worst
nations where Christians are being
persecuted, 37 are Muslim. Okay? So, we
got that. Now, Christianity, okay, so
the Old Testament certainly is full of
violence. The New Testament, you're
right. I myself am an advocate. I I
wrote a book called the two swords of
Christ where I reference Jesus in Luke
uh where he tells his disciples um
whoever doesn't have a have a sword go
sell your garment and buy a sword and
they say look Lord here are two swords
and here that's enough
>> now to modern day Christians of course
they allegorize this into
meaninglessness it's it means nothing
okay
>> uh to preodern especially medieval
Christians it meant that two swords you
one is a spiritual sword against
spiritual enemies which modern day
Christians I think still um acknowledge
But but the second sword is a secular
sword against material enemies. Okay?
And that's what they don't acknowledge.
Okay? So I I myself do believe that the
New Testament certainly makes room for
just war. Now the pivotal difference is
this. Okay? So I mentioned the texts and
then I mentioned the actual teachings
and codification. I don't know of any
Christian theologian who calls who says
we have to do holy war until the world
is converted to Christianity. Okay?
Because the texts don't support that.
They do support self-defense, defending
the innocent, the widow, the orphan, and
etc. Okay, but they don't and there's a
different and there's one more other
aspect to this which actually the Old
Testament. If you look at the Old
Testament, the violence that God,
Jehovah, Yahweh calls on the Hebrews to
engage in, it's always directed against
finite temporal people who have a name
and an identity.
>> They fight the Jeb, kill the Jebusites
and the Hebusites and etc., etc.
>> Interesting. Yeah.
>> Those people no longer exist. So even if
I'm reading that, these are not even
real people. It it's it's localized to a
finite group and time. The Quran doesn't
do that. It's very open-ended language.
It says in the present fight the
non-Muslim, even though at the time the
non-Muslim could have been a Persians or
Astrian, a Byzantine. Okay. So it it's
taken on a transcendent eternal logic.
It's not just, you know, okay, yeah, the
Hebrews were fighting the people in that
region and uh you know, that's the end
of it. So I think that that's a big
difference in my opinion.
>> So
when I go to an Islamic museum
and I went to one where there are
scriptures written all over the wall in
Melbourne, I noticed that they're all
from the beginning of the Quran.
Talk to me about that and talk to me
about the law of abrogation.
>> Sure. Um so okay so the law of the law
of abrogation which is the most
important part which in Arabic is called
which means that which is abrogated and
that which abrogates
is basically the idea that okay so the
Quran is supposed to be believed that
Muhammad recited it that's what the word
Quran means to recite uh according to
what Gabriel the angel told him to
recite and it's supposedly based on you
know literally the words of Allah as
delivered to supposedly it's almost like
the Mormon idea there's a steel with the
same words in heaven in Arabic and so
so the Quran was recited Muhammad
supposedly gets his first uh revelation
around 610 and they continue until uh
632 when he dies. Okay. Now they got
just thrown into a book later on as the
Quran and they're not and and they were
actually organized by length. A surah is
essentially a chapter and they just put
the longest chapter first and the
shortest at the very end. If you read it
like that, it literally makes no sense.
I mean, at best it's poetry and you
don't even know what's going on. Which
is another reason why the hadith is so
important because the hadith talks about
events in his life, right?
>> That then Muslims correspond to what's
being said in the Quran and then they
try to make sense of it.
>> But there are contradictions within the
Quran. So the apologists that you
probably meet often will tell you things
like the Quran says there's no
compulsion in religion.
>> Exactly.
>> You have your religion, I have mine.
Right.
>> That is in the Quran. Okay. But here's
the thing. Muhammad, it's in Muhammad's
career when he started preaching and
speaking the Quran around 610, he was
living in Mecca. And so the Islamic
scholars have have differentiated two
phases. There's the revelations, the
verses that came out when he was in
Mecca, the older ones. And then there
are there's the ones when he went to
Medina. Now, when he was in Mecca, he
was outnumbered. He was weak. He had at
most something like a hundred followers.
And he was being bullied and pushed
around by the pagan kurish tribe. That's
when he said, "You have your religion. I
have mine. Let's all respect each other.
Okay? Let's let's learn to coexist.
There's no compulsion in religion."
That's when that came out. Then he did
in 622 the Higra where he went
>> Oh, that's right. He went to Medina and
now he became a tribal warlord.
>> He became strong. He had followers and
then all of a sudden God started or
Allah started giving him more militant,
more aggressive offensive going on the
offensive verses
>> and those are in the end of the Quran.
>> So yes, because it's now his later time,
right?
>> Yes. I asked my Quran teacher this. The
there's no the law of abrogation isn't
in the Quran.
No, there is actually a verse that says
something about uh you know we give you
something but when a better thing comes
along we'll give you that.
>> Interesting.
>> Okay. So the idea is Allah is giving
Muhammad these rules as he goes along
but as Muhammad's circumstances change
Muhammad Allah gives him a different a
different motus operende to follow. So
if Muhammad is weak uh you know then he
obviously is telling him well don't rock
the boat tell them we all live now
you're strong. Well, now so the verses
for example that I said 929 and 95,
okay, those are the latest uh surah 9
surah Toba and those ver those are the
most militant verses. They're the ones
that say 929 says fight the people of
the book until they pay tribute or die.
95 is even more open-ended. It just says
lay and wait for the pagans wherever you
find them. Kill them, ambush them, and
take them as slaves. Okay, those are
much later. That's the final word. So
it's seen now amongst Muslims that this
is Allah's final word. He gave him the
more tolerant ones earlier on because it
was necessary. And the other view which
is actually even more dangerous is
Muslims say this and I've encountered
this often. They say yes both versions
the Mecca and Medina Quran meaning the
tolerant one and the more violent one
are still perfectly applicable and it
depends on where the Muslim finds
himself in society. So if you find
yourself in a weakened position, you
should preach uh the the peaceful ones.
You have your religion, I have mine. If
you find yourself stronger, then you
should also go on the offensive. And
I'll I'll I'm going to share with you a
final amusing anecdote.
>> Sure. Sure.
>> Which deals with a Somali. And uh this
is back at the Library of Congress where
I worked. And uh you know, he was a
pious Muslim. And I actually liked and
respected him, you know, and because you
know, he's he's he's I know we we don't
share the same theology and philosophy
ultimately. Okay. But you know, he was
he was a nononsense kind of family guy
and very traditional. Okay. And we would
have debates though, theological
debates. He was kind of like the
patriarch of his clan.
>> And I mentioned all this because he was
telling me, "No, you're wrong." He
seemed radical, but he would tell me,
"No, Islam is peace. It's not." He would
do all that.
>> So one time in the cafeteria, I kept
pushing him and telling him the story,
and I kept saying, "Well, what about the
Mecca verses versus the abrogation?" And
I said, "Meccah is when Muhammad's
weak." And this is how he asked. And he
finally got frustrated. And he said,
"Well, what do you want from me? I live
in Mecca,
>> meaning DC, meaning I'm outnumbered. I'm
around infidels. Of course, I'm going to
say this." Okay.
>> Oh, that's interesting. So, so do you
believe that peaceful Western Muslims
are practicing
>> I think Say the word
>> tea. Tea.
>> Yeah. And that's another deceit. Do you
believe that peaceful non-Muslims,
peaceful western Muslims are practicing?
>> I believe a lot of them could be and I
know a lot of them have been caught
doing this. You know, there's stories of
I I remember writing about a story in
Turkey where uh a group of Muslims uh
went to a church. Christians are very
minority there. And they went to a
church and they got to know the pastor
and his family and they feigned interest
and some of them got baptized and then
they got busted. It was all a big plot
to murder him. Okay? Like that's the the
lengths they went to just to do it. So
deception in Islam is a permissible
thing and especially in the context of
tea. Okay.
>> In the service of the religion only
though, right?
>> Okay. So the thing about tea is its most
authentic expression is you are being
you know persecuted and uh so it's very
different than Christianity. If I'm if a
Christian comes to a Muslim, puts a
sword to his head and says, "I want you
to renounce Muhammad," you know, the
traditionally a Christian martyr says no
and he dies.
>> Right. Right.
>> Muhammad himself actually advocated,
yeah, tell them renounce me, renounce
Islam and uh do whatever you have to do.
Okay. So, it's a very pragmatic take,
but yes, the tea or the deception in
general is a real thing. I wouldn't say
every single Muslim's doing it. I think
a lot of real Muslims actually are
dissatisfied with Islam. I think they
would leave it if they could without
repercussions. So I think some of them
are also they could be uh sincere.
>> Are there so is there any actual data or
concrete evidence of of rates of deceit?
>> Uh I think
>> how would you get that?
>> I don't think I mean can you imagine
Europe actually trying to conduct that
kind of survey?
>> How politically incorrect that would be?
But I do know I' I've read about
oftentimes you know a Muslim terrorist
>> and they lie in the survey. So it
>> Yeah. Exactly. But also, I've read about
Muslim terrorists being arrested and
then they go through a rehabilitation
program in the UK where they tell, you
know, they they give the moderate
versions and have them play ping pong.
>> Oh, yeah. In Melmo, Sweden, they have
the same.
>> Yeah. And uh and then they pass with
flying colors and they go, "Okay,
you're" and then a week later they let
them out and they go and commit another
terrorist crime.
>> Right.
So, uh, you know, it's just it's
unfortunate because Islamic deception
mixed with Western stupidity and naivity
is just a really bad combo.
>> What would you do if you were
surrounded? And they pulled out their
swords and they said, "Raymond, convert
to Islam or it's off with your head."
What would you say?
>> I guess I would I would I would do some
tea, maybe.
>> I don't know. I don't
>> because you're a Christian. So, what
would you say? I you'd have to put me in
that situation because you know what?
It's very easy for me to say I would say
cut my head off. You know that that's
probably my instinct if I wanted to give
you a bold answer. But I don't know when
the time comes who knows what would
happen. I hope I would stand for my
principles because death is not the do
all and be all in everything
>> because you believe in an afterlife.
>> I do believe in afterlife. I'm not a
materialist.
>> Yeah,
>> we should have this conversation.
>> I can I'll have any conversation before
you want.
>> You want to have it now?
>> Anything. So one of the issues and I
think this is what plagues Europeans and
Westerners in general visav Islam but
really this is a fundamental issue I
think and um you know let me start it
this way okay uh you're an avowed a
atheist
>> avowed I don't know how I am I just
don't think there's sufficient evidence
to warrant belief but if I were given
the evidence I'd believe
>> okay okay fine I'm not talking about you
but let's say what I'm going to say is I
think
>> talking about me that's fine
>> okay I think atheists are actually um
intellectually equally uh honest with
themselves in the sense that their
conclusions match their premises. And I
think the main premise of an atheist of
a western secularist is that they're
materialists in the sense um not in
hedenistic sense but that they their
epistemology is governed by material.
>> Yeah. I'm a naturalist.
>> Yeah. Okay. Exactly. So the only thing
that's real to you is what you see and
can feel with your senses.
>> Uh there's no supernatural realm for me.
>> Right. In other words, as long as long
as you can see and feel it, it's real.
But if I give you an abstract idea or
even God,
>> no, it's a little more nuanced than
that. I mean, as we're sitting here in
LA and Dawkins has very kindly given us
his studio,
>> this space, he is also a naturalist. I
think that naturalistic explanations, I
always seek a naturalistic explanation
and you can de facto rule out any
supernatural explanation for any
phenomena.
>> It's like Oak's razor, right?
>> Kind of. Yeah. is I just don't there's
just no evidence at all for the
supernatural.
>> No, no, I get it. What I'm saying is I'm
just trying to make a distinction here
which is basically that
>> maybe I'm not getting it. So go ahead.
>> No. Yeah. All I'm trying to say is that
I think western the the western
epistemology in general is materialistic
which means it only acknowledges that
which is physical,
>> the material realm.
>> The material realm. Okay. I'm I'm with
you. I buy that. Yeah.
>> Okay. And I think even I think that's
how an atheist would describe himself.
And so their conclusions match that.
>> Correct.
>> The problem is you have these religious
people and in the current context let's
say Christians in Europe and in the west
who claim to believe in okay God. And
then once you believe in God what you've
done is you've accepted the
metaphysical. Okay. Now you're talking
about that which is beyond the physical.
I think the word spiritual is actually
synonymous with physical which is ironic
because a lot of Christians will say I'm
a spirit. I'm spiritual.
But you're not. And this is my point. I
think a lot of Christians even though
they say they believe in once you say
you believe in God well it's not just
believing in God it's believing in a
whole host of morals and ethics and a
whole system
>> but that entire system is metaphysical
okay that's the whole point and I think
Christians despite themselves despite
what they say
>> are materialists and so when it all
comes down to it all they really still
believe in is the physical which means
yeah they'll tell you don't hurt someone
don't commit murder that's the absolute
worst but historically
Christians, you know, physical violence
was, yeah, of course, that's frowned
upon. It's a sin to kill. But that was
the least of the bad sins, errors that a
person can do. Most of them had a
metaphysical substance to them, which is
to say they were abstract, which but
today, even amongst Christians
themselves, there are no abstract
truths. The number one good is do not
physically hurt someone, right?
>> Because they're materialists. So when
you apply this kind of logic and you
look at Europe and what's happening with
Islam, well Muslims are not like that
because Muslims actually do have a phys
metaphysical system and a code of ethics
which is above and beyond the physical.
Um so I think when you put those two
groups one which you know all it
believes is in hey let's just not
physically hurt each other that's all
that matters but anything else goes and
the other group actually has a very
rigid and somewhat draconian system that
passionately believes in. Okay. Well,
yeah. I start seeing your point about
maybe it's time for them to capitulate
the Europeans because it's a lost
battle. And I think a lot of it actually
has to do with this lack of metaphysics.
>> Yeah, that's really interesting.
>> Are given that it would seem you you
don't have a kind of polyiana attitude.
Are you pessimistic about Europe,
Western Europe?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Oh, I'm very pessimistic.
Um,
>> do you think it's in hospice?
>> Yeah. I mean, you can say I do as well.
I I think if people I think the problem
is Europeans and Westerners in general,
>> their brain is just has been so
compromised and adultled. In other
words, if you could bring back let's say
uh let's go back a hundred years ago and
bring back your average European person
and just show them what's happening. I
don't think they could believe it in in
a million years. They would think this
is like a movie. This is not real. This
is my country, Britain. Now it's become,
you know, like 30% or London's been
taken over by Muslims who are openly
engaged in jihad and then my government
is putting people in jail for noticing
it. You know, I don't think they could
even begin to comprehend. And so that's
>> the barriers around Christmas markets
that you see in Western Europe, not in
Poland or Hungary.
>> Yeah. I I just I can't I that's what I'm
trying to say. It's been a slow slippery
slide. You know, the burning the the
what was the um the boiling frog
analogy. I was like that because it's
just happens slowly and you get inured
to it and you're accustomed to it and
you just think that's how life is. But
if you can like bring someone back to
see what's happening, I just I think
they could not begin in a million years
to understand what's going on. That's
how crazy it is.
>> So you and I share that view. We are
incredibly pessimistic about Western.
>> Oh yeah, I'm very pessimistic. Um I
think it's going to get it's going to
have to get much worse before get
better.
>> For sure. you know, and uh western men
>> unless they capitul unless they
surrender
>> unless they surrender and western men
specifically are going to have to stand
up and stop standing behind their women.
>> You know that won't happen.
>> Well, and if it doesn't if it doesn't
like you said they are destined to uh go
extinct and I guess well
>> yeah I agree. Hey if I have no sympathy
for any species or human who doesn't
want to preserve themselves.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. And what I am seeing I agree with
you this is it's selfdone. I mean a lot
of them again will point to their
leaders right but it's like at what
point are you going to realize your
leaders don't have your back and you
know pointing at them and complaining
and waiting for another leader. I don't
know that's just not going to happen.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's interesting. Where do
you stand in terms of the future of the
US with this issue? Are you optimistic,
pessimistic?
>> I think the US is just essentially
follow I mean and a lot of Americans
like to tell you we're not like the
Europeans. No, I think you're America's
on the same trajectory. Uh not
necessarily with the Islam, but due to
the demographics because Muslims in
America are not nothing like in Europe.
Uh they're still here obviously and
they're still a factor.
>> And they're skilled. We import skill.
Yeah. There's a different
>> Yeah. And they're more assimilated
because they're fewer in numbers.
>> And we have a history of assimilation
that the Europeans don't have.
>> Yeah. Yeah. See, that's the thing. When
you go to Europe, you know, it's like uh
America is a hodgepodge. I mean it may
it started of course mostly white but
you know you had you know Europeans you
had Irish you had Germans then you had
Italians and you had Spaniards and you
had the French so it always had that
sort of you know but you throw in a
Somali in Sweden you know it's like you
got Swedes and then you got Somali okay
it's it's it's very stark so I do think
America is a little more um conducive to
assimilation in general this is not to
say that there isn't
a potential Muslim problem, but you know
it at this point it's just due to the
numbers and demographics, it's nowhere
near as like France or the UK.
>> Yeah.
>> But it's on its way.
>> I mean, are you concerned what's going
to happen to the world when when Western
Europe falls?
>> Am I concerned?
>> I'm concerned. I'm even more than
concerned. I mean, yeah, concerned, but
it's just look, if people don't want to
if if if in your own vein, you know, if
people don't want to do what's needed to
do, then what what I'm one guy, what am
I going to do?
>> Yeah. I mean, that's how I feel. I'm one
guy, too.
>> Yeah. At at that point is when I start,
you know, worrying about taking care of
myself and my own because uh society
failed. Hopefully, it doesn't. The good
thing though that we and I think we can
talk a little bit about it because
you've alluded to it a little bit is
Eastern Europe is not like this. Eastern
Europe. Not at all.
>> So, in a way, it seems like, you know,
maybe the uh
>> I have my own speculation as to why, but
>> Well, why don't you tell me?
>> I think it's because they survived
communism
>> and Islam.
>> And Islam,
>> right? Because pro, you know, Hungary
was under 150 years of Islamic rule.
>> Yeah.
>> Or Victor Orban said that once when they
said, "Why don't you want to take in
immigrants?" He said, "Because we've
lived under 150 years of Islamic rule
and uh we don't want anymore."
So, The Two Shores of Christ, published
by Bombadier, your latest book, please
tell me about it.
>> Thanks. Uh, it actually it fits in very
much with everything we're talking
about, ironically, and that wasn't even
my intentional goal, but it just goes to
show you how everything is sort of
converging to the same point. One of my
fores is the history of military
interaction between Europe, Western, the
West, Christendom, and Islam
historically. And uh this book does the
same thing, but it it's written through
the lives and the and the eyes of the
military orders, specifically the
knights of the temple and the hospital
against Islam. And um what's interesting
about that is is you know here's a
perfect example who these guys were and
what they became. These were for their
times the most pious religious
Christians that you can think of. Okay?
And I I'll give you a little bit about
their origins, but let's talk about the
hospitalers for example. Who were they?
They were the first hospice. They're the
founders of our idea of a hospital.
Okay? And uh when when Christian
pilgrims would go to Jerusalem to visit
the holy supplr in the holy land, they
would get attacked by Muslims. And even
if they didn't get attacked by the time
they reached there, they were walking
from Europe. They'd need a hospice. So
the hospitalers were just monks who were
dedicated to serving travelers,
Christian pilgrims, giving them rests,
you know, food, aid, healing them, you
know, basic medical services as they
needed. And then they so and and the
verses, the biblical verses that they
would quote are things about, you know,
loving your fellow man and, you know,
very the sorts of things that your
average western Christian thinks is
great because it's good and passive,
okay? And it's loving. But then they
soon realized that you know what instead
of always waiting until a Christians
come and get savaged by Muslims which is
what happened because you know even
though the Holy Land was under crusader
control it was still a kingdom in an
Islamic sea surrounded by Muslims. So it
was it was normal.
>> So they decided that okay we're now
going to protect Christians before they
get killed. And so they became
militarized in that sense and they
became you know one amongst the most
feared warriors on the one hand but on
the other hand they still maintained the
charity the benevolence the they were
hospice workers so on the one hand
they're in the field fighting brutally
on the other hand they're like washing
people's feet and feeding them and
giving them their beds and taking care
of their so I mentioned that to you and
and one of the reasons I wanted to write
it is to show you just how on the one to
to a modern Christian that doesn't even
make sense.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. They understand the first part,
the hospice and the mercy,
>> but that that can be fused with
militancy. They could not begin to
comprehend. And yet they the these these
Christians did and the Templars, it's a
very similar story. Uh did and they
quote the Bible and they refer to the
Bible and there there's this and that
verse. Yeah.
>> So, yeah, my point is it's, you know, as
much as what I call doormat Christians
of the West today are convinced that,
you know, you know, their religion
begins and ends with themselves being
dmats who must never ever object or
complain or criticize and and that's
what God wants. That's what Jesus is all
about. You had these guys who were the
complete opposite. They were actually
much more pious than your average
Christian. Okay? But they did something.
They fought and they were violent uh and
they engaged in holy war. So I find I
find their example very interesting uh
including for our times as a lesson um
you know of it's it's not this idea and
I think honestly when we talk about the
death of Europe it's this idea that's
taken hold that to be a Christian is to
be a doormat. I honestly believe that is
the background of it. And you know, of
course, you will say, well, a lot of
Christian, a lot of Europeans are
atheists. It doesn't even matter. But
they they too, Haven't you noticed that
your average Western secular or
Christian and your Western, you know,
secularist are kind of like in
interchangeable? You can't tell the
difference. You know, they live the same
way. They see the same thing. And this
goes back to what I was saying is that
they're both materialists even though
one is uh intellectually honest the
atheist and one is not because he claims
he believes in metaphysical ideals but
he doesn't.
>> Yeah. Two things. My friend, my very
good close friend Arm Mutar said
something to me that was very
interesting. He's a a guy from Iraq.
He's like the most American person I
know. He founded Ideas Beyond Borders
and he translates enlightenment texts
into Arabic. And I asked him,"Wh doesn't
everybody want secularism? Why do why
doesn't the most hardcore Muslim want
secularism?" And he laughed and he said,
"Well, my reasoning was then he could
practice his religion. You could
practice your religion. A Jewish
Christian, she could practice and
someone could practice no religion." And
he laughed. And he said, "It's not that
they don't want you to practice your
religion. It's that they want you to
practice their religion." So their de
facto the default is against secularism.
>> Yeah. I think religion itself is is the
de facto against secularism because
think about what it implies.
>> Yeah.
>> You know if if if Christians get along
and and they say, "Hey, atheists, you
can live with us." And of course, this
is this is how it is, right? Atheists
and whoever live together. I think the
flaw with that and what other and and
what preodern Christians would object to
that is it's implicitly admitting my
religion is not true.
>> Yeah. You know, and not a lot of people
want to do that because once you do
that, once I if I as a Christian say,
"Hey, I believe, hey, Jews and Muslims
and Buddhists and we're all equal."
Well, inherent in that idea is that I'm
not right.
>> Yeah, that's correct.
>> Right. I mean, if we're honest with
ourselves, it sounds good. It's good for
coexistence, but inherent in that idea
is that so why am I following this
religion?
>> Yeah. It's not true. I had wondered if
>> and I'll just throw this throw this out
there. Let's say that you believe you
you're a Christian. I'm not a Christian.
Like maybe we need to cultivate people
who have your belief system as a bull
work against
Islam. But if I say that to an atheist
and and I don't mean obviously every
atheist and yes I'm I'm broadly
generalizing but atheists are largely in
the orbit of critical social justice.
They're largely on the editarian left
and they don't see any difference. They
see a kind of weird combination of
relativism and egalitarianism and they
would be like, "Well, why wouldn't I
want to live under Sharia?
>> Why why wouldn't I want to
>> like, you know, queers for Palestine?"
>> Right. No, no. What you're saying, and
again, what you're saying actually ties
up to what I was saying with this sort
of dichotomy about material and
metaphysical.
>> Exactly. Exactly.
>> Because the atheist, why wouldn't he? Of
course, it's all physical. As long as
you're not hurting me and I'm not
hurting you, then who cares? The rest is
relative. Okay.
>> Um the problem is is is that too many
Christians think the same way. So I
agree with you that Christianity
historical traditional muscular
Christianity is needed as a bull work
because that is what kept is remember
historically Islam conquered threearters
of the Christian world. Most people
don't know that. And what prevented it
from actually taking over Europe when
Islam was the behemoth, when Islam was
the powerhouse, especially in the guise
of the Ottoman Empire, was that
Christians fought tooth and nail and
were convinced that that was right, was
to fight.
>> You'll never have that again.
>> Yeah. Okay. So that's that is what kept
Islam out historically. Now the West is
much more powerful than Islam
militarily, economically,
infrastructurally.
Um and it's suffering. Why? Because it's
lost that spirit. this which was fused
with Christianity believe it or not. Um
so I agree with you that on the one hand
the atheists the leftist um the
paradigms that they operate under are
such that they're fundamentally
relativistic humanistic you know social
justice warrior nonsense. Uh so what's
left is the Christian paradigm but the
problem is too many Christians are
materialists and therefore subscribe to
the same leftist um delusions.
>> Precisely. I remember reading a case of
a woman who was raped by an immigrant
and they caught the guy and she insisted
that they she didn't want him prosecuted
because she feared he'd be sent back.
>> I've even read about one I think in
Norway or Sweden where a man was raped
by I think a Somali.
>> Oh yeah, that's right. Yeah. Yeah.
>> And he did the same thing
>> where I don't want him sent back because
he might get hurt.
>> Yeah. You see what we're dealing with? I
mean, I don't
>> This goes back to your point about
suicide. Yeah. And it's like, okay,
there's no help for that, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I find the whole thing incredibly
depressing.
>> I I really do. And but you you know
what's what's and I'm going to ask if
you think there's a glimmer of hope, but
you know what I I think I find many of
the the Muslims with whom I interact to
be really honest people. Like that's
what I find. And when I speak to some
people, I won't name them. They be like,
"Yeah, we're gonna take over." I'm like,
"Well, there's a guy I respect, right?"
No, but you can totally respect that.
He's completely honest with you. I do.
>> He's like, "Well, and that's also a guy
you can have a conversation with." Like,
I really respect the Christians when
they say, "You're going to go to hell."
>> Yeah.
>> I completely respect that. That's a
person you can have a conversation with.
They're not like, "Well,
>> they have convictions.
>> There's many gods and we all have our
own way.
>> I respect whatever you want, you Like
that's just give me a fucking break.
Like what the fuck?
>> Like just be honest.
>> You're spineless. You have nothing to
offer. Okay. Um give me something. Give
me a belief. Give me a conviction even
if I re if I reject it. Um Yeah. And
that's the other thing about Muslims,
you know, I think we spoke about this,
but that, you know, I like Muslims.
>> Yeah.
>> People are surprised to hear this.
>> I actually do too.
>> Like if you put me in a room of Muslims
and they don't know who I am and what I
write, I can get along with them pretty
well.
>> You know, I'll start rapping in Arabic
and, you know, we'll be fine. Yeah.
>> Um and uh we'll we'll see eye to eye
about a lot of things because they're
monsters.
>> They're trans.
>> Yeah. Like I I actually like to do
jiu-jitsu with Muslims. I find them to
be excellent training partners.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. They still believe, you know,
look, they they're masculine.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. You know, they still believe
I'm a man. She's a woman. I have my
>> They know what a woman is.
>> Yeah. Yeah. They figured that out.
>> Yeah. When they when their parliament
talks about what a woman is, they can
answer it. So, wow. Oh, they're heroic
in that sense, right?
>> Yeah. Uh, do you have anything that you
can offer people to be a little hopeful
because maybe, you know, people in
Western Europe are watching this or
>> Yeah.
>> Do you have anything?
>> I don't want to give false hope because
that's that's all they've been getting
is false hope and that's what's made
them complacent.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So, no, you should be scared. And
I think a lot of and another reason that
too many Europeans don't care and it's
very selfish and but they've been bred
to be selfish is because you know what?
A lot of them don't have children
anymore. They're not even having
children.
>> And so a lot of them, I think, in their
minds like, you know, I'm whatever my
age is. I I'll be dead soon. I won't
have to deal with a full takeover. It'll
be good enough for me. You know, I think
that's also kind of the thinking. It's
very selfish. So really the hope is the
younger generation that uh you know they
stand up and and you know this Gen Z and
uh they seem in many ways kind of very I
always have this theory that you know
generations they get worse and worse and
worse but there's some possible hope for
this Gen Z because they seem to sort of
uh be above they break all the molds.
>> Yeah.
>> You know so they're not necessarily
sissies and whatever and they may be
maybe
>> sissies. I love that word.
>> You know what I mean?
>> Yeah I know. I love the word. Before we
go to the lightning round, may I offer
some hope,
>> please?
>> My hope is that the Overton window is
moving on. Surrender. It's moving on.
And the sooner you accomplish this, the
easier it's going to be. The lower your
tax will be. So, I think that's a reason
for hope is enough people will have
received a critical mass now where
people realize that the civilization is
over. How would you not not getting not
not necessarily give me detailed
logistics but like
>> the logistics I know
>> no nothing detailed but just like a
general overview when you say surrender
because I'm I'm sure a lot of people are
saying like what are you talking about
surrender to who who's surrendering like
what do you mean
>> you know for example the UK and Western
Europe we could div
>> let's look at the UK like what should
they do
>> we would divvy it up between various
Islamic states maybe we could
>> give the northern Wales and Scotland you
know
>> so dissolve basically the parliament and
now and and let Muslim countries rule it
and they'll rule you justly because
you've given in.
>> Yeah. And the sooner you do it, the
better. I mean, I think that's the
reason for optimism here.
>> But you're
>> you're not being physician.
>> No, but I'm going to tell I'm going to
tell you something. You're laughing now,
but you're not going to be laughing in
10 years.
>> You're not going to be laughing in 10
years.
>> I'm not laughing because I think this is
>> you're going to be like, "Holy shit,
that was precient."
>> Yeah. Okay. Maybe. And but it but if it
is, man, that is If it is, then you know
what? They deserve it. They deserve
wars. That's what I'm telling you. They
deserve worse.
>> But I'm telling you, they deserve it. If
that's how bad it is that they could do
something, but all the all the I mean,
you're talking about the worst people in
the world that they basically gave up
all their land and all their rights that
their forefathers fought and died for
and these guys because they can't do
anything but sit around and hashtag have
given it all up. So, yeah, they deserve
the worst that they get.
>> Okay. Well, let me I go around the world
and I ask people one simple question.
What would it take to change your mind?
I'm going to answer my own question.
Here's what it would take to change my
mind that surrender is inevitable. Stop
illegal immigration.
>> No,
>> if you can stop illegal immigration, I
will believe that you have your society,
your civilization has a chance of
surviving.
>> Now, this is obviously directed to the
leaders, right? Because they're the ones
who are in charge.
>> They're not going to do it. But if but
that would be my defasibility, my
condition under it. I mean, I utterly
impossible
>> to stop immigration.
>> No. Well, they just have
>> Hungary doesn't do it.
>> Poland.
>> Yeah. Hungary is fined Hungary is fined
a million euros a day if not taking
migrants. And you know what I have to
say about that? It's a fucking bargain.
>> It's a bargain
>> because they can actually celebrate
Christmas.
>> Yeah. Well, Reed and I were there. We're
walking around. We're hanging out. Did
you ever feel threatened or unsafe even
one time that, you know, I mean, so I
just think
>> as opposed to London or
>> Well, yeah. Or or France and Re are you
going to go into some of places in
France where people would be headed? I'm
pretty excited about that. And we're
going to talk to people and we're going
to have my goal is to have honest
conversations with people about this.
And again, I've have Muslims on the
show. I have you on the show. I have
Islamic apologists on the show. Anybody
my golden rule is I will have anyone on
the show who has not harassed me, you
know? Like you're hyper qualified. Like
you can't just be a random dude on the
street. So you have the credentials and
you want to be an Islamic apologist. I'm
happy to have you on the show. Like I
believe in I genuinely believe in
>> You believe in debate, not censorship.
>> I do. I believe in discourse. I believe
in conversations. I try and it's more
interesting to people if I get a mixed
range. It's more interesting to me.
>> So, uh I'm going to do a lightning
round. Are you ready?
>> Sure.
>> Okay. So, the lightning round will
consist of a few questions and
>> it's going to be off color again.
>> Well, we did a thing in New York.
>> Uh talking about you and me.
>> Well, you me and Callum, we did
something in the comedy seller in New
York, which is great. That video will
come out soon. That was fun.
>> All right,
>> people are going to like that. So,
here's the lightning round.
>> If you had to import 1 million
Indonesian Muslims or 1 million Somali,
which would you choose?
>> Indonesians.
>> Why?
>> Because I'm familiar with Indonesian
culture and society and crime rates. And
I'm the same with Somali and they are
completely different.
>> Okay.
>> Meaning that the former is much more um
acceptable.
>> Okay. If you had to gain one oppression
variable, for example, woman, black,
gay, disabled, etc., which would you
choose and why? Yes.
>> Uh,
is it list them again?
>> Woman, black, gay, disabled, etc.
>> Woman, black, gay, I'll take, etc.
>> Really? Some other some other
impression.
>> Well, yeah. Some something that has no
name to it. Really in interesting
interesting
>> because that leaves the door open,
>> right? Okay. So, what would that be?
>> Well, you said etc.
>> Yeah, we got to pick one.
>> Is generic.
>> You got to pick one.
>> Um, well, how about a bad knee? I really
do have a
>> I have a bad knee, too. So, disabled.
>> Yeah, physically.
>> Okay. All right.
>> I mean, I'm not I don't want to be in a
wheelchair, but I already am disabled,
so I I'm I'm familiar with that. The
other things I just don't know.
>> Okay. Well, this is perhaps the most
difficult question of all. So imagine
just for a moment that I'm I'm the
leader of a trans rights movement.
>> Make the case to me as to why I should
support your vision of America over an
Islamic
vision of America.
>> That's going to be very hard. And I
think we already touched upon this uh
the whole materialist versus
metaphysical thing because the trans
person by definition I think is beyond
relativist. Okay. I think to be a trans
you have to be a relativist which means
there's no right or wrong. There's no
absolutes. There's no truth. Okay. So,
how and my vision uh I don't know what
you mean by my vision. You mean like a
Christian traditional society?
>> I don't know. Whatever it is.
>> Um uh as opposed to an Islamic one.
>> Yeah.
>> Well,
>> well, I'm I'm the leader of I'm of a of
the of a trans I'm the prominent leader
of the trans rights movement. They say,
"Well, why should I take your vision of
America over the Islamic version of
America?" Because the Islamic version of
America is actually and it's part of
their law is to execute homosexuals
specifically
>> like in Iran they all convert
homosexuals. They just give them
surgeries, right? There is no
homosexuality in
>> heard about that. I don't know how legit
that is. Uh I don't know if that's like
a fake thing,
>> but they do that to gays, not trans
though
>> that they they they
give them surgery
>> in Iran.
That's my understanding. I don't I know
I've heard that and it's been going on
around lately. I would really be shocked
if that's what Iran does. That is so
contrary to everything else I know about
that country.
>> Forced gender transition, but I I'm
certainly open to
>> it. May I don't know, maybe they have
like one or two cases, but I don't think
this is something that's like standard
there.
>> So, what would you say if if again I'm
going back to the quiz for Palestine
thing or the quiz for Hamas thing, which
we've when Reed and I were at UCLA, we
explicitly saw that. So why is your
version of America better than an
Islamic like Islamic the the you or your
>> because my version of America I would
not have uh trans or homosexuals
persecuted
>> or killed or anything like that. Um I
wouldn't also at the same time to be
honest with you especially the trans
stuff I would not validate that. I
wouldn't have that you know publicized
and celebrated. what happens to them
>> to trans people like in your vision of
>> they can do whatever they want but it's
kind of like I don't want this stuff
being pushed on children are
impressionable we have a responsibility
for young minds
>> okay and it's not right to kind of put
sexual confusion in the first thing they
have to encounter right away when
they're young I don't mind you do what
you do in your own home that's I I
certainly don't want to enter in
anyone's house and arrest them I could
care less
>> people can do what they want in the
privacy of their own home
>> it's a but but don't normalize don't
standardize it especially when we have
vulnerable, innocent, impressionable
minds. Okay, let them actually grow up
their own way and if they end up going
that way, they go that way. But don't,
you know, this is kind of like a
grooming thing.
>> Should two women be able to kiss in
public?
>> Uh, I won't stone them. Okay. So,
>> Okay. So, what does that mean? Yes or
no?
>> Should they
>> should they be allowed to?
>> Uh, I don't know. What are the What are
the laws? Don't we have like indecency
laws? I don't know if it's covered or
not.
>> Should should a man and woman be allowed
to kiss in public?
>> Um, you know, I'm not too fond of that
even that just to show you that it's not
even about homo homosexual or
heterosexual. I just think intimacy
should be it shouldn't be cheapened like
that. I think uh intimacy is good. But
when you do it kind of publicly um you
know and I don't want to be such a
prune, but it's just I don't know. I'm
I'm not going to enforce a law
personally, but I do know there's
decency and decency laws.
>> What about handholding? Should two women
or two men be allowed to hold hands in a
romantic way in public?
>> That reminds me just of a funny anecdote
when I went to Egypt um and I was
younger. I didn't understand this, but
like every guy walking around, every two
guys had their arms like it's called
engage.
>> And I just remember looking at one of my
relatives who I just met. I'm like, "Is
everyone here gay?"
>> And they're like, "No, no, no. This is
just this is like good friends, you
know.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Um so anyway,
>> you don't have to worry about that after
the interview when we're at dinner.
We're good. You have to that you can
wipe that off your your plate. So should
should two dudes be allowed to hold
hands? Should two women be
>> I don't Yeah, that's I'm not going to I
wouldn't enforce a law about
handholding. Even the kissing thing, I'm
just I'm expressing my own personal
belief. I just don't I don't think
intimate acts should be publicized. It's
just kind of like cheap. That's all.
>> Yeah. Well, whether it's a man or a
woman, you know, just kind of like uh
unless you have this overwhelming desire
to kiss your, you know, this woman or
whatever at this moment, but I don't
know. It's not my kind of thing.
>> Okay. Well, I
>> I'm a traditionalist.
>> I would have to plead plead guilty to
that. Um
>> I mean, we we could all plead guilty.
I'm not saying it's just a matter of uh
>> you know, you're asking me my views, but
again, none of this none of this I would
enforce as law. Okay. My personal idea.
>> I wouldn't want to do that,
>> right? Okay. So, a couple more
questions. You've been generous with
your time. Thanks. Is there anything I
should have asked you that I didn't ask
you?
>> Well, I mean, we did a lot about Islam
and the West. Um,
>> I guess one of the themes I was thinking
about the other day, and this is not
even a question, but I'll elaborate on
it a little bit if if a moment. And, uh,
I, you know, I actually, this is, it's
so funny because I wrote a lot of
articles from like 20 years ago, and
they just keep coming to my mind is how
applicable they are, right? One of them
was a little diddy I wrote and it was
called the Islamic schoolyard bully.
>> And what I explained in an article and
basically what it comes down to is I
think the schoolyard bully paradigm is
so well at is so good at understanding
Islam today. And what I mean by that is
okay so what is the schoolyard bully? So
he shows up and he you know you meet him
and he sizes you up right away. Okay.
And he sees how much he can get away
with. Maybe he starts pushing you
around. He wants your lunch money,
>> right?
>> And the more you acquies and give in,
what does he do? He gets more
aggressive, doesn't he?
>> But then if you give him a big shot, a
punch in the nose,
>> doesn't work.
>> You give him a punch in the nose, he
actually becomes like your best friend.
And uh, you know, he looks up to you.
>> That to me, as someone who's very
familiar with the history of Islam is
very much uh emblematic of Islamic
behavior historically. Okay. And
>> you have studied this for your whole Oh,
yeah.
>> This is what you literally
>> This is what I do. And so I'll give you
an example from history. We already
talked I think people get the idea about
the jihad and the violence and the
attacks on on the west and all the the
non-Muslim world. But in the colonial
era, okay, the tables were changed.
Okay, this is when remember people don't
realize this because they always when
they think of Islam in the west, it
starts with the colonial era in their
mind, right? Exactly.
>> And they think like, oh, Muslims are
always these poor brown people being
abused by these white imperialists.
>> Actually, it was the opposite. for a
millennium, Muslims were the ones who
were the stronger attacking the
Europeans.
>> Okay. So anyway, finally you get the
colonial era and what happens is you get
a very dominant European western
Christian culture that spreads out in
the Islamic world and what do the
Muslims do? Do they rise up in violence?
They actually immediately get in line
and try to copy them as much as they
could. The number one Muslim country
that was the scourge of Europe or the
Ottoman Empire essentially in Turkey is
the first one to actually turn its back
on Islamization. It gets rid of the
Arabic script. Turkish was written in
Arabic. Yeah. Out of Turk and then they
adopt the Roman alphabet. They got rid
of the beards and the Islamic dress. If
you look at pictures of Egypt or Iran,
people know that. But even, you know,
the countries you don't think of as
being moderate in any way, like I said,
Egypt
>> Yeah. Yeah. from the 30s and 40s and
50s. All the women are in dresses, their
hair is down, no one's wearing a hijab,
they're in high heels, all the men are
in suits and ties, clean shaven. Okay?
And this is like the 30s, 40s and 50s.
So my logic is when the west exuded
power and confidence. What Muslims did
is they gravitated towards it. They
wanted to it's like, you know, the as
Osama bin Laden said, you know, everyone
likes the strong horse,
>> okay? And they followed it. And but at
the same time, what's happening now is
the West is buckling, losing confidence
and becoming acquiescent and appeasing.
So let's go back to the schoolyard
bully. And guess what? He's now starting
to lose respect. And he's starting to
push him around. And the more the West
says, "Oh, whatever you want." And you
know, but I don't mean to judge. And the
more he spits at it and pushes it and
attacks it. Okay. So I think that is a
very useful paradigm to understand it.
>> Yeah. It's interesting if if I may
relate a a story. I was teaching a new
atheism class years ago at a university
I will not name
and I had a question on the midterm.
Is Islam a a race? I had I can't
remember exactly but it was something
like um multiple choice and then I think
fill in the blank and some and then
extensive essays like five essays pick
three something like that
>> and the is Islam is a race. yes, no, or
true, false, something. And the kind of
the hint that I gave people before this
is you can't convert into a race. Like I
can't say, well, you know, tomorrow I'm
going to be Japanese or Southeast Asian.
And I had so many people complain about
that question that I had to remove it
from the
>> What's the complaint?
>> Does it matter?
>> Well, yeah. I'm trying to
>> Well, their sensitivities were offended.
because they believe that Islam is a
race.
>> Because they believe that any kind of
identification on racial grounds with
anyone
is a kind of the a moral a moral wrong
and people can weaponize the idea of
Islam against people who are of a
different race. So I couldn't ask is
Islam a race or Islam is a race. I can't
remember exactly how I phrased it
because that itself was considered to be
racist and I had to remove it from the
test bank.
>> I think acknowledging the word race
makes you a racist at this point based
on what you're telling me.
>> Well, yeah. You should have seen when I
was in Crazyville. I mean, it was like
truly peak crazy. Okay, so last
question. Is there anything at all you'd
like to ask me?
>> Uh, Islam in general or
>> anything. Anything you want about
anything.
The only thing I don't talk about in
these interviews is my my personal life.
We'll save that for dinner.
>> All right. Yeah. Okay. Let's say you do
want to see Europe make a comeback and
uh you know what what are you what what
what would you have it do? What are the
steps?
>> Awesome question. That is an awesome
awesome question. The first order of
business is you have to stop
immigration. There has to be an a
moratorum on all immigration.
I don't think Europe is capable of being
honest with itself at any level about
anything.
>> Let's stop with that. Why?
>> Um I think they don't think that there
are things worth fighting for. I think
some of it is white guilt. Some of it is
colonial guilt. I think it's a
combination of Gad said suicidal
empathy. Coin that phrase. I think it's
an idea of you know I know Muhammad.
Muhammad's a good dude. Therefore, so I
I think I think that factors into it. I
think relativism and egalitarianism have
eaten us down for so long. I think that
the principles, the first principles and
the fundamental principles that bound us
are
they're corrupted and corroded. I think
the mainstream media outlets are organs
of the left. And if I say that, that
doesn't mean I'm on the right. That just
mean that's a a criticism. And I think
they've been fed healthy dosages of
propaganda for decades. So I think that
the ocean of propositions in which
people are swimming, I I don't even
think that they realize how bad the
problem is, how bad the situation is.
>> And so the first order of business is
you have to end migration because if I
lived in a sane world, I wouldn't say
that. Here's what I would say. We have
to acknowledge that certain immigrants
are net detractors from the Treasury and
they're guilty of they're they're it is
more likely if someone comes from
country X that they will be incarcerated
>> and less likely if someone comes from
country Y Japan being the paradigmatic
but you can't say that because because
people are not the problem they're not
well they're not capable of the nuance
>> you can't say truth is what you're
saying
>> right well that's the other thing Europe
is in this problem because of first
principle because they have failed to be
honest. They are not. They are lying
>> and they continue to lie. And I mean I
don't live there. I mean what am I
supposed they've had enough Americanity.
I don't live there. Trump has said
they're going to take away NATO. They
got problems. The Russians. The polls
have conscription. I mean we got Europe.
Europe has a lot of problems. But the
first order of business, you need an
absolute unconditional moratorium on
migration. The second order of business
is I'm going to say this, people are
going to lose their shit, but it's true.
You have to start shooting people if
they attempt to come over the border.
>> Yeah,
>> there's simply no other way to keep
people out.
>> No, I actually
>> But if somebody has another way, I'm
completely willing to to listen to it. I
think the cameraman left. He was Did
that offend you? I think it offended him
so deeply he left the room.
>> Are you serious?
>> Yeah, that's why he left. He shook his
head and he left. But I don't know what
what's what's the other what's the only
other solution to that?
>> Yeah. Um I think
>> let's bring the camera guy up here and
ask him his solution. Get him up here
and we mic him up. Mic him up and I'll
ask him what his solution
>> actually because your position is not
that bad. The point is why are you
breaking the law? Okay. You're breaking
the law and there's repercussions.
You're not the innocent one here. I mean
in other words, I agree with you.
>> But if anybody else has a solution, I'm
willing to hear the solution. I mean I
don't know what the solution would be
other than you have to have a moratorum
and if people try to come to the border
you have to shoot them.
>> The thing is you know I've said
>> what is the other solution?
>> The thing that I've said before which I
just people don't get this is you know
especially Europeans and Americans I
might have told you this before but
>> you know when you look at the world
population whites are like six 7%.
>> Yeah. They're already a minority. Yeah.
And yet it's they who have who feel it's
their job, their moral right, their
moral duty to always let everyone take
their country. Yeah. Even though they're
the tiny minority and uh you know, the
world is flooding with blacks and browns
and yellows or whatever, but the whites
are the ones that it's you know, oh,
you're a bad person because you don't
give up your land.
>> Hey, if you dis if you disagree, did you
leave because you disagreed?
>> Um, no. No, I just needed to go use the
bathroom real quick.
>> But you didn't leave cuz you disagreed
with anything?
>> No, no, no, no.
>> Oh, okay. Cuz I'm going to say if you
disagreed, I'm more than willing to have
a conversation with you about it.
>> I appreciate that. Maybe we could do
that at the end of the shoot.
>> I mean, we'll get it on film right now.
>> Um, I appreciate that. I don't feel like
um
>> if you don't want to appear, maybe he
can ask it and we can speak without
>> Yeah, I mean, if you can ask us this
question. I mean, you can ask me
anything.
>> Strong feelings about
finding the murder of Charlie Kirk
absolutely wrong, which I agree. But
then to say in the same sentence,
um, we should be shooting people for
just being a refugee, trying to flee
violent conditions, trying to make a
better life for themselves.
>> Okay.
>> I mean,
>> give it to me in a sentence cuz I'm
going to repeat what you said. I want to
make sure that I get it right.
>> Sure. I just think it's uh you're either
I don't think you can denounce political
violence um especially like really nasty
political violence like shooting someone
um while calling for that political
violence against your who people you
judge to be political enemies.
>> Okay. So I just want to get this in a
sentence. So your problem with what I
was saying is you don't think I can
denounce the murder of Charlie Kirk and
advocate for shooting people who come to
a country illegally. Did I get that
right? Yes, that's right. Because I
think laws are um you know, I think laws
are
um inherently um malleable. I mean, at
one point it was illegal for a black
person to go into a white only
establishment.
>> Yeah.
>> Um I think that a refugee, for example,
has a right
>> to come to who's fleeing violence has a
right to come to another country. So
what I found offensive though is just
you saying shooting
>> those people because
>> to me that is similar to what you were
denouncing earlier which I agree with.
We shouldn't kill our political enemies.
>> I think calling for shooting and killing
people that you have that disagreement
with.
>> To me that that made me feel about how
you would probably feel if someone said
they were pro shooting and killing
Charlie Kirk.
>> So what would your solution be to
illegal immigration in Europe?
Well, I think Muslims make a small
percentage of the immigrants in Europe
or the population in Europe. It's
something like 5 to 10%. Um, I don't
think immigration is actually a problem.
If you look at statistics, um,
undocumented immigrants commit less
crimes and less violent crimes.
>> But that doesn't answer the question
though. So, what is the solution to
illegal immigration in Europe?
>> Well, I gave you it does answer the
question because you're So, in your
question, you're implying that there's a
problem that needs to be solved. So the
way I'm answering that is I'm saying
that implication is false. Okay?
>> And the and the facts don't support your
feelings about the issue. And the facts
are that especially in America,
undocumented immigrants commit less
crime.
>> We're talking about Western Europe.
>> So we're talking about Western Europe. I
believe the statistics are fairly
similar. Um I looked it up while you
were talking and there are more hate
crimes against Muslims than there are
hate crimes against Christians. And I
understand that's a topic of debate, but
to pretend that a minority that's 5 to
10% of the population is somehow
oppressing 80% of the rest of the
population, um, I just I don't think
facts support that. And I think calling
for shooting people, I think is is over
the line. I think that's over the line
in the same way that you probably felt
when you saw someone shot and killed
Charlie Kirk because they disagreed with
him. I think that's um I think that's
just deeply objectionable rhetoric
especially right now.
>> Okay. So I just want to make sure I
understand your position correctly. So
you don't think there's a problem with
illegal immigration?
>> I think whether immigration is legal or
illegal is arbitrary.
>> Um so you think that we should allow
people to come to not
>> you you had based you had based your
argument on the idea that people are
coming into this country without being
quote unquote vetted.
>> Right. Right.
>> I'm talking we're talking about I just
want to be clear. We're talking about
Western New York to this conversation.
>> Well, um I think basically if there's
not a legal process to immigrate, then
the term illegal immigration becomes a
misnomer because what you actually have
a problem with is immigration, not
illegal immigration, immigration in
general.
>> What if a country said we don't want
immigrants? Is that okay?
>> If a country said what?
>> We don't want immigrants. Well, and I
would say that um I'm a white person.
You're a white person. You're a white
person.
>> I'm not a white person.
>> Um I apologize for assuming if you're
not white and I apologize genuinely for
that.
>> Um my ancestors came to this country and
there were other people living here.
>> Let's say let's say Europe, we were
talking about Europe. Let's say the UK
says we're British and German says we're
Germans. We don't want non whatever into
our country. Do do they have that right?
Well, and what I would say is that's
when we back up and we look at the
history of imperialism. If you want to
talk about violence, if you want to
talk,
>> but yes or no. I just I'm looking for a
yes.
>> Well, of course, you're looking for a
simple answer because um but what I'm
actually doing is rhetorically unpacking
what you're implying and how that breaks
down once you
>> No, no, it's a country saying, "Look,
we're a sovereign nation. We are the
country."
>> Okay. But I was answering that. So I was
answering that you have to look at for
example why are there so many Muslims uh
immigrating to Europe
>> because it's a better life there
>> because uh in over the last couple
decades uh the US with their European
allies killed over a million people and
destabilized the entire region most of
the people coming to Europe are refugees
from European actions so it's entirely
hypocritical to say that you have no
right to be here when we and
>> you're making a humanitarian argu
argument. In other words,
>> it is a humanitarian argument.
Absolutely.
>> Okay. Okay. So, I'm just trying to think
of how this translates into policy.
>> Sure.
>> In the context of Western Europe
specifically.
>> Sure.
>> So, does a country have a right to say
we're going to close our borders?
>> I think that immigration is a human
right?
>> Okay. In the same way,
>> should just just to be clear, I want to
be clear in if Saudi Arabia said we
don't want non-Muslims. This is our
country. We are a Muslim country and we
don't want non-Muslims. Do you have a
problem with that?
>> Absolutely. I would say that's deeply
oppressive.
>> That is what they do.
>> Exactly. And that's what that's my
thing. I'm against that sort of policy.
I'm against bigotry. I'm against uh
closing the borders. I'm against um I
think people I think immigration is a
human right. I'm against uh
dictatorship. I'm against uh the
dictatorship in Saudi Arabia. And I'm
also against oppression of of Muslims
here in America as well. I believe in
freedom which means the freedom to be
Christian and the freedom to be Muslim
wherever you are in the world.
>> How about the freedom to have my own
country without anyone coming in?
>> I don't think that is a reasonable no I
don't believe in that. I would describe
that and to give you an analogy I would
say that say the Jim Crow era someone
could have made a similar argument. Do I
have the freedom to go into a place
without people of different races? And I
would say no because that's impinging on
their freedom and that's not actually a
free society. But I mean America is a
different example because the you know
slaves were brought here. I get that.
>> I'd like to keep talking about Western
Europe. I mean if you really want to
talk about America we can. But we're
talking about He
>> I think that the issues are my analogist
but I understand. Go ahead.
>> He asked me my solution for what should
be done in Did I get that wrong? You
asked
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Like Yeah. What what
does Europe need to do?
>> We started with the UK and then you
called for shooting people. And so that
made me feel about probably how you
would feel if suddenly I called for
shooting someone um who you who you
would respect.
>> See, can I answer to that because it
strikes me as a little different. Here's
what he's saying. I think is this. We
America is a sovereign nation or any
nation, not just America. Let's say
Saudi Arabia. Saudi Arabia decides we
have borders and we don't want anyone
coming illegally. Okay, you can maybe
apply legally and we'll figure it out.
Okay, we've made our position known.
This is our nation. These are our
borders. Now, once someone knowingly
says, "I'm going to try to get there."
Isn't that kind of their fault? They've
now stuck themselves, they've put
themselves in this position where
they're the bad guys. Whereas the
Charlie Kirk example, no, this is a
person who said, "I don't like your
political views and I'm going to murder
you." So, I don't really think they're
analogists.
>> I think that um let's agree on one
thing. Uh killing someone is really bad.
>> Yeah. Shooting and killing someone, but
I made a law. This is our land. You're
an outsider. That's how the world works.
Every country's like that.
>> If someone were to propose that we
shoot,
>> you chose to break in.
>> If someone were to propose that we shoot
and kill uh say people who uh violate a
speed limit, I would say that's very
gross and very bad.
>> Yeah. Well, okay. But
>> Okay. So, now you understand. Now you
understand that just because it's
illegal that proposing to shoot and kill
them, that's deeply offensive.
>> I'm saying that because we don't do that
and nobody respects us and they do it
and they break the law. So obviously the
the response has to be raised up and it
the the repercussions have to be greater
not because we want to do that but
people need to respect and fear the law
that's how it works.
>> So you feel that anybody should just be
allowed to come to Western Europe who
wants to come?
>> Uh yes I believe that
>> well that's a that's a different Okay.
And also I would go so far as to meet
you halfway and say there should be a
vetting process. And this is my issue
and this is the big issue is because
that's not
people aren't being refused access
because they're being vetted and it's
determined that they're not allowed
because they don't meet some
requirements. They're being refused
access because in mass uh they only
allow a small amount of people. So, it's
not that people are trying to get in
who, okay,
>> fail a vetting process. It's that
immigration itself is being banned and
that's being pretended like that's about
a vetting process. But it's not about a
vetting process. It's about excluding
what I feel like as a human right, the
right to leave a war torn country and
make a better life for yourself.
>> Okay, so let's go back to the original
claim.
He asked me about Western Europe. What
would I do? When I asked him, "Are there
any questions you'd like to ask me?" And
I went through a litany of things that I
thought I would do. I mentioned
shooting. And if any of this my
recollection is an error, please let me
know.
You I'm jumping ahead. You offered to
meet me halfway and say you think we
should have a vetting process.
My argument to you would be you haven't
answered the question. What do you do
with people who go to Western Europe
illegally? you still have people coming
in danger.
>> I would say that it's a I would say you
would treat that like a minor crime in
this instance if one that it is actually
possible to immigrate um if you pass a
vetting process which by the way it's
not um you need a lot of money and a lot
of resources and they only allow a small
amount. So realistically, immigration is
not possible for people. But two, if
someone does break what I would consider
a minor crime, which is crossing a
border, that they should be treated and
that should be assessed in the same way
of, for example, somebody speeding,
which is a minor crime that would
require appropriate consequences and
not, for example, shooting them.
>> Okay? And I and I just to say why I
walked out. Um, one of my best friends
is an undocumented immigrant.
>> Yeah.
>> And um, you call say suggesting that he
be shot for what I don't even consider
to be a crime.
>> Is he in Western Europe?
>> Uh, he's not.
>> Okay. So, let's go back to this. So, we
we have the country of the UK, the
United Kingdom in England.
We've agreed, we make a law. We say
we're going to vet people and we still
have what is it Matt Goodwin's statistic
in Eric Kaufman 183,000 people entering
the country and you want to treat that
like a speeding violation.
>> Do you know how many speeding violations
there are a day?
>> No, I just want to make sure that I
understand the argument.
>> Yeah, that's not basically I don't think
it's a crime to cross the border. Border
it's a totally
>> the truth. I think you don't even care.
Like if someone breaks and and enters
illegally, I think you think it's okay.
you probably are rooting for them,
right?
>> Because that would be a crime. I'm
saying it's a crime to break into
someone's house and steal something and
if someone does a crime, they should be
punished for a crime. I'm saying it's
not a crime to immigrate.
>> Do you think given so you don't believe
in sovereignty of a nation?
Uh I mean honestly I think that um
sovereignty is largely um something that
is used to oppress people. Okay. All
right. Well, that's good. Thank you for
being honest. So now I know exactly what
you believe. And so
if we try to agree upon something and
meet me halfway, I don't think that's
meeting halfway because it doesn't
answer the question. The
>> I think I answered your question, but
>> well, the idea is that there is there
any number of illegal immigrants that we
shouldn't like if if
10 million people wanted to come into
the UK or on dingies in a year, we would
just treat that like a speeding
violations for those individuals.
>> Um, realistically, it would be fine. Um,
the number you That's honest. That's
honest. the number the number you
proposed was I think hyperbolic um and
would
realistically when we when you look at
the facts when uh undocumented or not
when immigrants go to a community that
community benefits
>> I'm not talking about the benefits
argument I'm talking about if people
there is no upper limit of people you
think before we say absolutely no more
>> uh that's right I think
>> that's honest
>> human human humans have since the dawn
of time uh been born to migrate. I think
it's a human right. Um I'm going to wish
you something. I wish to consign you and
your family and all of your posterity to
lives that you want to create because
you're pretty much going to create that
in Western Europe. And I wish that to
consign you to that life. I wish you to
give you the very thing you want. I
would wish nothing else upon you than
that.
Uh,
sorry. I'm I'm not understanding what
you're trying to communicate to me right
now.
>> I'm trying to communicate in the context
of Western Europe, you're getting the
world that you want
>> and it will it is. Yeah, I'm positive of
that. All of the data indicate that that
the world that you're advocating is
coming
>> and we can we'll see the consequences of
that.
>> I mean, I think all of the world has
lots of problems, but I would say the
biggest one is racism and im
anti-immigrant racism. authoritarianism.
I think those are the big problems. And
I ultimately think when you're comparing
things like violence against Christians
and violence against Muslims, you have
to go back like 10 20 years. A Christian
country killed a million Muslims in an
invasion in the Middle East. And that is
the context in which this immigration.
>> Which country is this?
>> What's that?
>> This was the United States.
>> The United States Christian country.
>> So George W. Bush during the invasion
very very he may have engaged in
terminology very directly said cited
God. Yes. If you look at the statistics
crusade. Yeah.
>> If you look at the statistics of
>> he wasn't doing it for Christian
reasons.
>> Almost all of uh almost every uh person
in power in this country is Christian.
>> I'm an atheist so I don't know what. But
I'm just I'm just glad that you were
honest with me and said there's no upper
limit to illegal immigration in Western
Europe because you're going to get the
society that you want.
>> Well, and I think that would be a better
society. And the reality is
>> we're about to find out.
>> You are what they call and I've never
really encountered one and I'm happy to
do so. And this isn't an offense, but
you are what they call a woke person,
aren't you?
>> Uh yeah. Uh I would say so. Um I think
um
>> and what you experienced when you
stormed out, that's called triggering.
Um, was I triggered when you uh when
somebody called
>> for uh the violent shooting of one of my
friends?
>> Absolutely.
>> Is your friend Western European?
>> Um, do you remember he is an immigrant?
You specifically called for the shooting
of immigrants.
>> My friend is an immigrant.
>> Illegal immigrants, not immigrants. And
in the context of Western Europe
>> again whether it's legal or illegal and
again undocumented person is the term I
use because it's arbitrary
>> use any term you want
>> uh it's arbitrary but yes um
>> so you think it's arbitrary you think
the conditions by which one should enter
the country so if someone
>> you said countries have no sovereignty
>> but if someone's a serial rapist a
serial child pedophile arbitary
>> those are interesting reasons why
someone would be denied access do you
think that's why people are being denied
access.
>> Those are interesting reasons that
>> I would support I would support denying
someone access who is guilty of those
things. That's not why people are denied
access.
>> And what do you do if they if a group if
a boatloads of them are coming over?
What do you do?
>> Um
>> what do you do? You're you're in charge
of the government.
>> That's literally how our entire country
was built.
>> But to answer the question, you're in
charge of the UK.
>> Well, I am refugees. I'm literally
answering it. That's how all of America
is built. Do you think of America?
>> All right. So obviously we cannot
distinguish between America and Western
Europe. I've tried repeatedly. So let's
talk about the United States then.
>> Okay, we could talk about the UK if you
want.
>> No, we've tried that. It hasn't worked.
So let's talk about the UK.
>> You were trying to suggest that it's a
problem.
>> Time out, guys, just for a second. We do
have to turn over the room in like 35
minutes.
>> Okay, so go ahead.
>> You know what? But I will say I
appreciate you hearing me out. It sounds
like we may have to end this argument.
>> Why? We have plenty of time.
>> Oh, I'm sorry. I thought I just heard
that we have
>> say we have
>> No, we have I'm totally You have
>> an hour.
>> I'm totally I've totally I'll totally
talk to you all day.
>> So I again we don't have to talk about
Western Europe if if that's
>> I don't think it's a problem when people
immigrate. I don't think it's bad for
the country.
>> Let's let's go back to answer
>> and I don't think immigration laws
actually stop people from immigrating.
They just create a lower tier of worker
who they can pay less and oppress.
>> I I hear you and let's go back to the
question. Okay. We have a boatload of
rapist, murderers, and pedophiles coming
in.
>> Completely false premise.
>> Well, I mean, it could happen.
>> Can you entertain the hypothetical?
>> Can you entertain that hypothetical?
>> Okay, I will entertain the hypothetical.
And yes,
>> in that case, that is a situation where
I would be sympathetic to the idea that
they would not be permitted access,
>> but they're on a dinghy. How do you
block? How do you not let them come?
>> What do you do?
I would say that um
>> he's going to bring them in and then
safely send them back.
>> I would say that in the current context
um there is no legal way to come in in a
vetted way. So
it's
>> so what do we do? We have a boatload of
people who are murderers, pedophiles,
rapists.
>> And this is also what I would say.
>> Yeah. What do we do with
>> undocumented immigrants are less likely
to commit crimes than citizens? This is
a hypothetical.
>> Okay.
>> I'm asking you a simple question. You
are the head. You're
>> Do I think people should be denied uh
immigration? Uh
>> no. No.
>> Based on past criminal history, I'm
sympathetic to that.
>> This is this is the this is the question
in plain language.
You're in charge of immigration policy,
in charge of the borders in the UK. You
know for a fact that boatload, this is a
hypothetical that boatloads of rapists,
child pedophiles, and mass murderers are
entering your country on dingies. What
do you do?
>> So I would say that how Okay, so for us
to have that information
means that uh we would be able to stop
them.
>> How would you stop them
>> physically? How would you physically
stop them?
>> What would you do to stop them?
>> Oh, uh detain them and then deport them
if potentially. I'm sympathetic to that
argument. My point is that
>> what would how would you stop what would
you do to stop them?
>> Uh the same way the same way you stop
someone who's shoplifting, the same way
you stop someone who's
>> apprehend them.
>> So you'd intervene in all the boats, any
of the boats coming in, you'd intervene
and vet people.
>> Uh not necessarily. I think um
immigration is a natural part of life. I
think for example if they are
for example the criminals you describe
that we should have evidence against
them that they did those crimes before
we detain them and stop them.
>> Wow.
Well, you're going to get exactly the
kind of Western Europe that you want.
We've already creating it.
>> What is What is so scary? What is so
scary about an immigrant to you? They're
less likely to commit crimes. I think
>> you said in the last Let me answer your
question.
>> I'm going to say I want to reduce the
crime. You just ask me a question.
>> This is what I would say.
>> Did you just ask me a question? Let me
ask Well, let me go ahead. You said in
my last interview with James Clo, did
you not
>> say that again?
>> You didn't you said in my last interview
with James Klo?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. and you explicitly heard me say
that I'm pro- immigrant, that I'm pro
H1B visas, that I'm vehemently opposed
to illegal immigration, and that it's
bewildering to me why people cannot
differentiate between illegal
immigration and legal immigration.
>> And here's the answer that I was
screaming in my head. Obviously, it
would have been inappropriate for me to
say it. It's very obvious. It's not a
hard answer.
>> Okay? The amount of immigrants they
allow is so small that it effectively
makes all immigration illegal. Meaning
it's not possible to legally immigrate.
>> Who's they?
>> The governments. These regula government
regulations.
>> What government? Who
>> all these governments? All western
governments. All the countries we're
talking about. My wife was an immigrant.
These um like I'm pretty familiar with
the process. It's when someone comes
here quote unquote illegally. It's not
that they were like too lazy or hiding
their criminal past. It's because these
countries don't allow people to
immigrate their rights.
that isn't it the nation's right to say
okay we only want x amount because we
don't want for whatever reason we don't
want our demography to be overwhelmed in
10 20 years
>> I would say I would say no I would say
that's not a right
>> genuine difference of opinion
>> and same reason I'm against Jim Crow
laws I'm saying if you're interested in
democ preserving demography
>> well that's how people sounded during
Jim Crow era they're saying hey if we
allow different races into these
>> here's the thing I think people like you
assume that the people who do this are
all white. Blacks, browns, and yellows
do the same thing. If you told them,
"Hey, we're going to introduce a
boatload of whites to the point where
you're going to become maybe a
minority." Blacks, browns, and yellows
would resist it even more so. It's not a
racial thing. It's just a human thing.
This is our country. We want it our way,
our culture, and our people. That's just
the world. It's not like a white racial
thing.
>> It's definitely a white racial thing.
You have to look at the uh culture of
imperialism. You have to look at the
direction in which people are
immigrating. So why is it that white
people are not refugees to Iraq?
>> Because nobody wants to go to Iraq.
Everyone wants to go to white countries
cuz that's where all the goodies are.
>> Oh, and what happened in Iraq to make it
so bad? It destabilized.
>> Why doesn't anyone want to go to Somalia
and Kenya and Nigeria and Afghanistan
and Usbekistan and Libya?
>> Britain. So did Britain or Europe have
anything interesting historically going
on in the last couple hundred few
hundred years in the country in the
continent of Africa?
>> Oh yeah. It actually brought medicine,
science, technology.
>> Okay. So you think colonialism is good
and I think that is such a fundamental
difference of opinion.
>> Africans say that Africans say that we
learned all that because before the
colonial era Africans were living
basically almost like on a stone level.
I think that's a fundamental difference
of opinion. Have you read anything that
goes contrary to your opinion? Have you
read?
>> I've been listening to it for the last
two hours while you while you sat there
saying nobody ever said like nobody ever
can present an argument against me. I'm
presenting them to you right now.
>> I can use another beer. H
>> Have you Have you read any arguments
against your position?
>> Of course.
>> Okay. Give me an example of something
you've read.
>> Um I just listen to all your arguments.
But have you read have you read Bruce
Gilly's the case for colonialism? That's
the seminal piece that
>> I mean I think this is a weird argument
tactic cuz I could also be like here's
my book that proves my opinion. You
should read this. Like why haven't you
read this? Like
>> what would you say about someone on the
other side if he had never read anything
who disagreed with him? Would you say
that he was ignorant?
>> So you think I haven't read things I
disagree with? I'm asking you give me a
specific
>> I guess he's asking you that um your
positions are they based on a deep
reading or are they maybe more emotional
and ephemeral based on social media
what have you read I think that actually
while you guys are up here talking I was
factchecking you which by the way I
would recommend getting a Jamie you know
from Joe Rogan's poke for example but
that doesn't that doesn't answer the
question the question is what no because
because it was implied that I'm
emotional
and I'm not facted.
>> And I would say that the opposite is the
case. I would say that I'm the one who's
looking at facts. You are the one who is
leaning on emotions such as bigotry and
racism to form your opinions and you are
backing into what you want to be true
against what is the reality.
>> Okay. So, let's answer the question and
then I'd like to come back and give you
an opportunity to address the racism
claim because I
>> is this all by the way like going to be
on which is fine with me. I hope so. I
hope so. So
you haven't read anything that was
positive about colonialism
>> or you say that the entire of course I
have I would say that's the dominant
ideology is what is colonial can you
summarize the colonial era like what was
uh pros or cons or all cons? What was
it? Um, I would say that that's a big
question and I don't think it's
>> as you know it in a couple sentences.
Yeah, I know you're not.
>> Sure. This feels like a little bit of a
trap because you're asking me to define
what is an extremely complex and big
subject. But to put it basically um I
would say that it is uh European powers
at a certain point in history basically
decided uh started carving up the world
and extracting raw resources from around
the world and engaging in uh genocide
and slavery and in fact that was a
obviously the foundation of this country
as well.
>> Okay. Let me ask you this. Um and what
you just said is actually pretty
mainstream. So um did any other
civilizations do this? Absolutely.
>> Okay.
>> And so
>> can you name one because you're familiar
with what you're
>> Absolutely. I'm against Muslim app
imperialism and American imperialism.
That's the difference between you and I.
You, for example, are bigoted against
gay people very clearly. Um
>> I'm not bigoted. I just uh you know,
>> and
>> but at the same time, you seem to you
seem to have a chip on your shoulder as
if you are superior to the bigotry that
also exists in Muslim countries. And I
would say that I'm against both forms of
bigotry. I'm actually against bigotry.
>> Do
>> I mean I like where he's going with it,
but I'm a little confused.
>> Yeah, I'm a little confused. Do you
think I'm against gay people, too?
>> Um, I don't uh know your opinions on it.
I would say the way that you answered
the question of um when you specifically
asked about um
>> holding hands,
>> same sex partners,
>> kissing hands, kissing,
>> also samesex partners specifically.
>> Yes. Yes, I detected that was bigotry.
You guys also use the term sissy, which
is a an anti-gay slur.
>> Is it okay?
>> I thought sissy means like a wimpy guy,
but okay.
>> That's what I thought. Maybe it's a
generational thing, but okay. So, I I'm
curious. What did we say that was racist
to you?
>> And do you think Islam is a race?
I would say that for example your belief
that Musl
that Muslims are somehow taking over
Europe when they are a minority that's 5
to 10% of Western Europe and um are
actually more susceptible to hate crimes
than um are likely to commit them. I
would say that that's a racist opinion
because it's not supported by facts.
>> You're using this word racist which
everyone knows has been weaponized. What
does that even mean? I mean, it means
judging people based on their ethnicity
or their race or the color of their
skin. This has been defined. This was
defined in like the 1950s.
>> But wait, wait a second. May is Islam a
race?
>> Well, I think race is a complex social
construct and that's the reality. And of
course, that's going to be a scary
answer, but that's the facts because if
you look at the way
>> May I ask where you were educated?
>> Uh, no.
>> I'm just curious. You went to college
clearly. Yes, of course. I'm not
answering that question.
>> Okay.
>> Um, that's a deeply condescending
question. I don't think it's appropriate
to what's going on right now.
>> Why? Why is that?
>> Because I wouldn't ask that to you.
Where were you university? I got my
doctorate from PSU. I went to form. I
got my philosophy.
>> I would say the reality is race is a
social construct. For example, inroups
and outroups are defined at different
times for different reasons. So, I'm
Irish and Italian. That's correct.
>> At one point that was not considered to
be a white person.
>> My grandparents were in the same
category.
>> Of course,
>> that is correct.
>> Uh so that's when I say racism is
definitely real. But in reality, race,
we are all one human race. Um and
race is a science is actually a social
construct is what my answer. But what
what is I'm I'm going to bracket that
for a second cuz I don't want to go down
that rabbit hole. What did we say that
was racist?
>> I thought we were talking about a
religion.
>> Well, things that they're saying.
>> I thought I thought I answered your
question. I would say it's racist to
suggest that Muslims are somehow
oppressing Europe by their existence.
That's what was racist because the
reality is they are a minority and they
are more likely to be subject to
violence than to commit it. In the UK,
in Germany, and in a lot of these
Western European nations, sex crimes,
for example, are wildly
disproportionately performed by Muslim.
>> I just got to feed my cats.
>> You're not pissed, right? All right.
Muslim migrants. Okay. This is
documented. It's wild. Do you accept
that? Do you accept that?
>> Well, I think we should look at the
sources because something interesting
happened earlier in this conversation. I
can do the same thing. You know, I can
say your sources are all made up. Well,
that's what's h that's what happened
earlier in this conversation is that you
made a pretty outrageous
>> which one
>> claim about churches being attacked
>> and you went on the internet and you
didn't find it and I also told you I
told
>> and when you were called to task about
to present that source you basically
said what people say when they don't
have a source or
>> no I said I'll go on my computer I have
the old links but if you do a Google
search you won't find is what I said I
can find it okay
>> now I respect that you
Fuck.
>> I don't think that stands up. I don't
think that's how a reasonable person uh
conducts things to say like, "Oh, I have
the evidence, but then I lost it cuz my
computer lost it or whatever."
>> I say my computer. I said that it gets
expuned off the internet. I'll write an
article to put hyperlinks to the
sources. They work. Three years later,
all those sources are gone.
>> Okay. I just want to go back to the
Clint because that's a that's a pretty
weighty accusation. I think it's a
weighty accusation that we said
something that's racist. And the idea is
that, and I want to make sure that I
understand your position correctly, the
idea is that a criticism of Islamic
immigration is by proxy a criticism of
race.
>> I would say that the criticism you got
uh that has been made here today.
>> Yes. The way that it was made is
fundamentally racist because it's
doesn't match reality and it is
basically rooted in the idea of I'm
scared of Muslims and I don't want to
live with them.
>> Okay. So let's talk
>> Islamophobe.
>> Uh yeah, he didn't say that. Well, but
we are you are in particular. You are.
So when you say the reality, are you
disputing the crime statistics that he
gave for example of Somali in Western
Europe? Are you disputing those
statistics?
>> I am. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, you're disputing the
statistics. So, what evidence would be
sufficient to persuade you that nothing?
>> Well, we would have to look at we would
have to we would have to sit down and
look at the evidence. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, if I gave you in detail the
evidence from Yan Vanderbeek or if I
gave you Eric Kaufman's data and you
showed and you looked at this data,
would you be willing to change your
mind? Well, and then I think first of
all
>> yes or no. Just yes or no. It's a
hypothetical.
>> Well, yes. I know you like to ask yes or
no questions because it doesn't allow me
to unpack the implications.
>> We don't have time.
>> Why don't you ask me the ask me the
question. Ask me the question.
>> I am answering your question. Your
question is would that change my mind
about immigration? And what I would say
is
>> No, that's not what the question was.
>> Okay. What was the question? The
question is, would it change your mind
that you said you accused Raymond in
particular of not operating in reality
about the crime statistics? If I showed
you those statistics about taking from
the Treasury and incarceration rates,
would you be willing to change your mind
>> about would I be willing
>> exactly what I just said about certain
>> about these arguments being racist? I
gave the example that uh Muslim migrants
in these various European countries are
wildly disproportionate in their sexual
assaults. It's something like out of
every 10, eight of them.
>> This is not the evidence I've seen. But
he said if you did see,
>> but this is a hypothetical.
>> Okay. So,
>> so hypothetically, if you were right,
you would be right. And hypothetically,
if I was right, I would be right. That's
how that works.
>> Okay. When you entertain a hypothetical,
you accept by fiat the condition of the
argument. So, hypothetically, if I gave
you data by I only know two off the top
of my head, Eric Kaufman and I can't
pronounce the guy's name is a
complicated name and but I've read both
of their reports. I've read it's but if
you if you had that and you s wow there
is something there's a there there would
you be willing to change your mind about
the
>> he would never accept it because he'd be
convinced it's a line
>> ch but you're sorry you need to clarify
would I be able to change my mind about
>> about the do we have to go are you
coming to get us out we have to leave
>> seven
>> I'm sorry if you had a loss
>> um yes that is why I walked out when you
described
>> it's around oh I'm sorry I'm That is why
I walked out when you described brutally
killing someone. That is
>> to talk about some of that. Well, all
right. Anyway, thank you for the
conversation and thank you for talking.
Thank you for giving your objective
to have a conversation.
>> I wanted to say this. I do appreciate
you talking with me and I want to say
that to you as well. I know we disagree.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And I do think that we both hurt each
other and I I do respect both of you and
um I hope some of that respect goes
towards me as well. I mean, I certainly,
you know, I think conversation is the
essence of this whole thing.
>> Absolutely. So, and I appreciate you
hearing me out.
>> Sure. Of course.
>> So, and I and I appreciate both of you
as well.
>> Come on, man. Thanks. Appreciate it.
Thanks. Yep.
>> Bring back the fire.
Bring back the flame.
Bring back the fire and the rightous
name.